this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses
viewer discretion is advised a very good
afternoon to you all far and wide from
the Masai Mara here in Kenya we have a
lioness over there my name is Lauren and
I do have big James on camera today has
a very hot day the lioness is feeling
hard I am feeling hot and I'm sure James
is too a nice 29 degrees Celsius and 85
degrees Fahrenheit
now believe it or not this is a shepherd
tree and this lioness was sitting
perfectly up in the tree for about
thirty minutes and of course just as the
show was about to start she decided to
clumsily I think she landed with quite a
bang on the ground and she's much more
comfortable lying on the cooler soil so
today we're gonna stay with her for a
little bit but please do talk to us send
in your questions and your delightful
comments using the hashtag Safari live
on Twitter or indeed on the YouTube chat
stream now we're having a bit of a
discussion about who this lioness is and
we're actually very close to our camp
we're not too far and we are in the
region of ole ole ole ole territory so
the all of us have made a kill a way up
the escarpment down the hill and they're
actually feasting on a zebra
so this lioness could indeed be part of
the hola Lola pride but we are still
trying to figure that out
we had a lovely view of her bottom
earlier and it is just now we are really
starting to get a look at her face so
still not confirmed exactly who she is
but we will get there and she does
appear to be completely on her own there
is not another lion in sight only
herself who was very comfortably perched
up this tree and obviously decided it
was not good enough and she decided to
come down so it was amazing to see this
lioness up here because it's normally
leopards you see up a tree and not
and so it was a fantastic start for me
and it's great to be with her
so we're gonna stay a little bit longer
and figure out who she is but for now
I'm gonna send you across to Diamond yes
it's quite interesting to see a lioness
go up a tree but I think it's more you
know interesting to see it also come
down because the Lions are not designed
either to climb trees or come down and
hallo hallo everybody Jambo Jambo a very
warm will come to this other side of the
Mara we are in the sausage republic my
name is David as usual and in the
on-cameras Bungay definitely Lauren has
to do everything but just as a reminder
don't forget to keep interacting with us
I'm talking of comments and questions
and as usual harsh Safari live well we
do not have a lioness but we got two
elephants and buffaloes maybe about six
buffaloes the two of them are standing
up and about for them that are laying
down and my guess is these are two
different species buffaloes and
elephants but my guess is all of them
are males but more so to the elephant
facing the right you see that from there
no question about it
that one is definitely a male now either
he is interested with some female
somewhere and not sure the one that is
on her left is a female I always want to
believe it's a male but we are going to
investigate you much closer but you can
definitely tell he is looking for some
male somewhere now I've always looked at
all the animals that I know of in the
African wilderness but I think the
elephants have the biggest appendices so
we're gonna have well he just turned the
other way we will not be able to have a
look at it and they were a lot of kilos
I'm trying to remember how much one
would weigh but it was a lot of
kilograms and she could be looking for
some females elsewhere to the far left
of the stew Ellis the Shogun gave can
see three little dots there and I'm
trying to imagine those ones could be
some sort of pigs
yes those are what hogs excellent Alissa
what hogs so in that one small area we
got what hogs we got buffaloes and we
got the Ellie's and the three different
species of animals have been brought
there by one commonality that area is
very green it's very lush and also
there's a spring of water so is what
I've always said water is life
and it's water that has put these three
different animals that are not related
together well to the far right Bungay is
another huge herd of elephants thank you
for that Buffalo and I think that one
male elephant is where it should he
should go because how to believe in that
particular hard there could be some
female but whether going they are not so
long as there's no female well that is
it it's just it will not help magic I
agree with you and just look at the
beauty of the monodrama apart from the
animals they're magic why didn't she
look at that landscape and I mean
sometimes when I look at the Mara I just
go wow I mean seeing three different
species of animals or spread out and Oh
existing very passively it's wonderful
isn't it magic
it's so quite well yeah I'm looking at
about being a mile or so away from where
all these animals are and as you know
Lauren Said's we've got pretty warm
temperatures I mean when we talk over 85
degrees Fahrenheit for me it's quite
warm or 29th degrees Celsius that Li is
quite warm but the long rains in Kenya
have started and humidity being high
temperatures going high is nothing out
of the ordinary this time around and
what you've seen the last few days is
like every afternoon we have got some
showers I personally feel a bit of you
know high humidity and maybe rather late
at night we might have some rain well my
plans today
ladies and gentlemen is to look for
lions and which I am I talking about
I alia said I am in the sausage republic
and definitely I'll be looking for the
sausages well myself and Lauren will
tomorrow trying on Kenya steve is in
Juma and I'm sure you'd like to say
hello to all of you
good afternoon everybody welcome down to
a nice sunny warm day and rumor where
the temperature is 32 degrees Celsius
and 86 degrees fair enough my name is
Steve I'm joined by David on camera and
sorry we just reversed back there to
frame up a red-billed honda calling
doing his very interesting little
up-and-down motion the red belt easily
identified from the southern
yellow-billed by well the red bull the
southern yellow-billed has got a very
nice yellow belt it also known as the
flying banana and this guy well
affectionately known as the flying a
chili pepper and as yesterday when we
had the yellow bull horn well on the
school Drive busy doing pretty much the
same as this sitting in the shade doing
a little bit of preening in the in the
heat of the day he's talking well she's
talking to his girlfriend somewhere
nearby but can hear them calling when
they do their territorial sort of
demarcation during the breeding season
the true them will stand together and do
that do that up and down bobbing motion
with their wings normally a little bit
more open and it adds a little bit of
sort of depth to the the call that they
make I don't really know how it works
and what about the look that they put on
is supposed to scare off intruders but
it seems to be the way of the Horned
--all
Monique most certainly not the horn
balls are some of the most common of the
birds we find around here the two most
common being the southern yellow-billed
and the southern red build horn ball
this one being the red belt and while
they're breeding successes are very very
good because they actually hide the
female away in a whole cavity in the
tree and actually cement it up with mud
and also some fecal component from the
female and there's just this little
keyhole split like that that the male's
able to come and feed her so they are
very successful in their breed and it
could have between one to three chicks
and if the season is a good one they
will successfully raise three chicks and
we've seen many many horn Bulls around
next to starlings and Dubbs Honda's are
probably the third of the most common
birds around and that's got a lot to do
with how they breed as all comes to be
successful they don't Margaret and
they've got fairly very good abilities
to switch their diet from insects to
fruit to whatever else they feed on
insects and fruit being and the primary
sort of driving force they'll also land
on the floor and scrape through the
elephant dung looking for an rotted I'm
looking for any grubs and insects that
might be growing in there I think this
might be his friend over here in the
tree or is that a roller that might be a
roller in fact another very very common
bird or am I seeing something completely
out of place I think I'm seeing a log
the the oh no there is a bird there Oh
darbie it was a dove there's God now I
thought I saw something that was not
that but anyway if it was a roller
they're also quite common we do see many
of them around but they not as prevalent
as the hornbills okay well we're going
to be searching for some tracks for
leopards and lions today see what we can
find out and while we do that let's go
up to the masai mara where lore Lauren
has already found a lioness
and here I have my lion I feel very
lucky to be with this lioness right now
we're still not sure oh she is because
look at her beautiful position flat as a
pancake as some would say so we're still
not sure but for from what we can see
definitely a young lioness definitely
young and I'm just wondering if she is
one of the young ones from the although
little pride or not the mysteries that
Lions throw to you you can just never
quite get round it but one of the good
things is that the breeze is picking up
on this stifling halti so it's given us
a little bit room to breathe and it also
does mean that it will start to get
cooler and the lioness will indeed start
moving at some point now just yesterday
we also had another lioness who made a
warthog kill and we just missed the kill
and of course it was cage drive so I
thank my personal feelings it's gonna be
a really good idea to stay with this
lioness for a little while once she gets
cooler I believe she will get up and you
never know what she's going to do I like
to figure out exactly who everybody is
before I leave the animal so although
she's flat and probably dreaming quite
happily from what I can see here I do
wonder what lions dream about although
actually maybe it's better I don't know
what lions dream about however she looks
rather comfortable but I assure you once
it just gets a little bit further on in
the day and the conditions change we
have got some dark clouds up ahead which
I'm a little bit worried about it but
the past two nights the rain has held
off so we hope tonight it also will hold
off and of course I am really intrigued
to see exactly what this lioness gets up
to and where she goes where's she gonna
go is she going to contact call and
reunite with her pride you never know
sometimes lioness don't like being on
their own they will go off on their own
they'll be independent they'll do their
own thing but then when it's time to
join the pride again they can get quite
stressed and they can repetitively
contact call and it's not the nicest
thing to see we need to pray they're
part of a pride it's who the
lionesses are rights so hopefully we can
maybe see her reunite with some others a
name the mystery could be resolved and
we could figure out exactly who everyone
is but for now our social cat has not
been very social and it's just lying
flat as a pancake now when we first came
to the site thing you could just see the
outline of a cat in the tree and from
very far away it's just like a leopard
it was extraordinary and when we got
closer of course you could see it was a
fat lioness perished right and the fork
of that Shepherd tree doesn't look very
comfortable from where I'm sitting
hey girl Kristen's asking do Lions love
climbing trees I've never seen them do
it in Juma but out here in the Mara it's
a regular things to see Lions climbing
trees the windows are famous for it
it will always see the old windows
climbing trees lions also love to stand
on their back legs and stretch right up
against the tree and sort of use their
claws to scratch sharpen those well
claws stretch their bodies you know bill
yoga position but climbing yes they do
so we also saw these sausage tree cubs
up a tree was it last night or the night
before I get confused but we saw them up
a tree so Lions do enjoy climbing trees
it's just not something that people
generally associate with lions and
they're definitely not famous for
hoisting their kills into tree and
Kristen kindly reminded me it was a
night before sorry the day's just roll I
hear when you're having fun so it was
not last night it was a night before we
saw the sausages of a tree so leopards
are the ones that are really designed
with those huge shoulder blades and all
the power and all the muscles in their
upper body to really not only pull
themselves up trees but to hoist their
kills as well they're notorious for it
but lions are
that's not what they do but I hear in
Namara they just love climbing trees and
it's fantastic to see I'm not sure why
and it's probably because it's really
not something that you see regularly in
Douma not saying it doesn't happen them
there but it definitely happens a lot
more common here so David is also
looking for his lions and I believe he's
now entered to sausage republic so let's
go and see what he's up to
that's very true Lauren and hopefully
gonna see more than that one particular
Eunice you saw you're gonna see if you
are in the olala territory that's one
area you might see one of the largest
prides that we got in the Mara triangle
well I stopped here just trying to
investigate what you have in those trees
up there but once I we have seen the
associative pride climbing all the way
up we see those huge rocks here there's
some big rocks that a boom guy is going
to show you a Bunga is the one who's
managing the camera today but notice the
sandwich today for the Lions that I'm
looking for those rocks we have
particular terms of an tops but you call
klipspringers
that will always go on top of those
rocks or if not they clip spring as
you've seen once in a while some little
animals that you cause I'm Lorent like
we call the hierarchies and the rock
hyrax they like to climb there but
before I go to Hoya I'm thinking I might
get the sausages I thought I would stop
and make sure I'm not leaving anything
behind the last I saw on those rocks up
there it was too small no curbs and I
guess they belong to the female called
Kingston and they were right on top of
that particular oak not that they could
be there today definitely they have
moved that was like way back to its ago
but again you never know so let's just
move on because it won't be long before
we smoke this
Leon's out would have done today's to go
to a totally different area an area have
not been for a long time where our
guests they could be hiding
well I've say this many times it's the
green season now and you don't have as
much prey as the lair should want I'm
sure Laura might have mentioned it or
not but without the wildebeest and zebra
it becomes a bit difficult for the ions
to keep eating and to keep hunting so
they have to deal with tougher prey I'm
talking about their buffaloes
and every time we are looking for this
particular pride I'm always fast looking
for buffalos and not once I'll say eight
out of ten times that's kind of trick
has helped me to locate these females
very very good so let me keep going on
and hopefully by the time you see my
face again we'll be lucky let's go back
to South Africa to Stevo
thanks Gigi good luck that side well we
are in the heart of Jummah i'm just been
following up on some alarm calls it was
a squirrel making a lot of noise they're
not the most reliable of chaps what have
you got there oh that was a really big -
really big warthogs running through the
gap over there those are the guys who
saw yesterday that disappeared on us
that monsters really big mud wallow just
over here that's a good place to check
for signs of animals but we were
following up on some alarm called
squirrels not being the most reliable of
LARM calls and then we heard and frank
him then we heard a couple of mongooses
and a go a bird shot 'ok look it is that
time of day you're not expecting to see
any sort of predatory animal moving so
the most most likely it's some form of
that of predatory bird hanging around
but so we're still gonna check her out
see if there's any tracks a little mud
wall over here is a nice last place to
check there's a lone buffalo bull who's
hanging around the property at the
moment I'm not sure exactly where he is
but he was seen somewhere close to here
this morning so a good place for him to
be would be ensconced in the mud wallow
to the right where we just had these
warthogs I just have a look
matt is drying up really really quickly
there's not much left to it these
seasonal muddy pans the runoff from
above the slope or from the top of the
slope bringing all of the clays and
nutrients down to the bottom
surrounded by quarry trees and the lack
these areas sort of dot around sort of
their Drive the river on area and in
these areas really good areas for
finding all sorts of wonderful animals
as this is prime habitat for day care
the eyelas warthog at the buffalo come
in and out and there is a lot of grass
around so we're hoping with the late
rains that we had and possibly the lack
of rain to the east that we're gonna be
getting the buffalo herds moving in
because you know what that brings that's
going to bring the Inka houma pride and
the Avoca males who seem to be setting
up shop
in buffa soup to the north I can't even
remember the last time we saw the uncle
Homer pride well someone is out as well
with me this afternoon I think he's
trying to fill up on some tracks of a
female leopard you know who he is
it's a good afternoon um I am out and
about and well this points a little on
the frustrated side which I know is only
given that you just gotten started but
we've kind of been following on tracks
and I'll explain why it's frustrating
and shortly but before we get into all
of that my name is Justin on camera but
since I this afternoon and it is very
nice to have you all aboard on a very
warm very pleasant sort of I don't want
to say summer because it feels like
we're not in some anymore weather's
changing so let's say autumn afternoon
now the frustration has come in is
because there was a I was sitting at
morning meeting this morning and we
heard alarmed calling monkeys and
squirrels and we kind of ran out of camp
and Steve spotted a leopard crossing
from the power lines towards sort of
Gallagher's side and so he came out and
found the tracks and so we followed the
tracks and they go straight to the pan
but the problem is is that I can't go
any further because there's people that
are in Gallagher at the moment sitting
watching the pan and I think they're
having you I mean maybe even suntanning
I don't know what they're doing but
they're their rights we're the sort of
dick is close to the pan so I can't go
there for now I have to wait until
they're done so I walked around as much
as I could on the sort of western side
of the pan and Colombo has been having
an absolute blast I say it's her because
the track is quite small and she's been
all over the place inside they're pretty
sure that's where the alarm calls came
yesterday but none of them are from
coming back this way are from today just
heard tracks going down towards the
water point and then the last track I
had was maybe 20 meters from where the
pan is and I had to turn around because
that's the age of the kind of thicket so
we'll have to go back there a little bit
later if we are to try and track you
down the thing is is that if it is
little Kalama and she is kind of in one
of those moods she could be long long
gone in the long hauls and steve is
hearing
could very well be her so being a try
and just kind of see what we can do that
we're gonna do a few loops further north
maybe up sort of towards a dam area and
then come back once the guys get mobile
where we can actually properly kind of
finish tracking that and see how far we
get and where she is I think she must
have found some shade and somewhere
close to the pan it's been a hot day
today and you know when should we saw
her the Sun had just broken through
because it started off quite cloudy this
morning and then just broken through and
we're starting to get quite warm and
after a drink off and lipids we'll go
and find a place where they can just lie
down and rest for the vast majority of
the day so let's see let's see how we go
but on other lipid news is very exciting
that's little what little I say little
in Kenya knee has got a new cub that was
seen for the first time today which is
very very cool very very cute she's tiny
tiny tiny I say she I don't even know if
it's a boy or a girl it's too small I
think to tell but super cute little
thing but tiny ears and it's still very
small I would probably say maybe only
three four weeks old
and so that's very exciting that there
is a lipid but the cub they are on very
far east of Torchwood
so we unfortunately don't get signal
where they are but cool that they're
around maybe they'll push a little bit
further to the west and given that
driving so winter months the signal and
tortured should start to improve a
little bit as the vegetation dies back
good so that's the plant for the
afternoon because we're gonna do that
for us looking to bumble about and see
what's kind of happening I'm sure water
holes will be the theme of the afternoon
in the meantime though let's send you
back across to Lauren who's had no such
frustrations this afternoon and is
already sitting with the twenty coloured
cat so indeed we're still at a loss of
who our girl is because she really
hasn't moved much at all but we are
getting different updates and the ole
ole ole O's are definitely really not
too far away with zebra
I'm afraid so that puts a little bit of
a spanner in the works but we're still
trying do not worry and of course lion
prides do have home ranges and within
the range they have their territories
depending on what their needs are at the
time so they're Roby
a central area for alliance territory
but when I when I think as a human we
often box things and we think that's a
territory but of course they are dynamic
and they are fluids so the boundary
lines do move from time to time it isn't
static and that is just where we're at
at the moment so my gut is telling me
although low low but I will come form I
always do I will revert back but that is
just what my guts are telling me at the
moment so obviously lionesses do
generally work as a team because it's
much easier for them so they sort of can
work together
it's easier to get rid of older lions
and their domain keep hyenas at bay
which is obviously the main competition
out here for lions so as much we're
having a little bit of a roly poly Wow
doesn't that look extremely comfortable
kiemas asking does she have cycle marks
very good question cuz she has a huge
fat belly but I do not see any cycle
marks and obviously she just gave us a
great glimpse of her belly before
turning over to the other side and I did
not see any suckle mark she does appear
to be young lioness sorry that positions
rather comical to me obviously
comfortable I don't know why that's
making me laugh there's no actually
particular reason for us this lioness
has brought me many chose from the
minute we met her I could get a great
photo of her jumping down the tree those
I will post that soon you can see it all
in action but she just keeps killing
herself and the most amusing positions
like this one right here but it is
obviously comfortable so yes thank you
ten great question but I don't see
soccer marks and I do think the fleas
are comical and now we're back to
pancake position they do love their yoga
lions I don't know why that was funny
excuse me sometimes animals just do
things that just crack me up when I
actually look at them no I know she's
flat and it's not the most exciting
thing to see but I really want to get a
better view of our better look at her
face and I really want to see where she
had so I want to finish this story so of
course we are gonna stay here with her
even though I'm very jealous of her at
the moment sleeping like that really
wish I could nap like I used to when I
was at university but those days are
long gone
could be the coffee could be aged was
most likely coffee he's saying she's
lying like my dog is lying on the couch
oh yes my beagle would lie exactly like
this as well for hours on end and I
always talk about my own made up
non-scientific term of the biscuit tin
effect and that is you will think your
dog is absolutely snoring she will not
respond to her name or his name or not
respond to any noisy's but the minute
you open the biscuit then we are awake
it's like magic don't know how it works
Lions are they accept removing again
Lions are the exact same as with
leopards as with all the cats you will
think they're in the deepest of sleeps
and they probably are but any movement
or any sin that they need to be alert to
they will jump up straight away and I
term it the biscuits in effect but
obviously Lions probably would not jump
up for biscuit ins however it's the same
effect and it is just utterly
fascinating and lions do have a terrible
reputation for sleeping almost all day
some papers give it up to 18 to 20 hours
a day which I'm sure they're absolutely
capable of doing but that's not always
the case
so lions are known to hunt out here we
see it often in the Mara journey even
under the intense midday Sun they will
also hunt at night and it just depends
on what they're doing I guess it just
depends on their daily schedule lie
can use a lot of energy on a hunt
especially a buffalo hunt that can seek
I was they will expend a lot of energy
it will be very exhausting for them of
course they will need to recuperate and
sleep at some point and that is exactly
what they do especially mothers if
they've got Cubs yes they are exhausted
and they often need to catch up on those
little catnaps themself so they can
sleep most of the day but they can also
be active for lots of parts of the day
as well do not underestimate these lions
and most likely this position is a new
position who looks very comfortable and
she probably is not going to move for
some time but we are absolutely going to
stay stationary for now but you guys are
gonna go all the way back down to South
Africa to see what Steve is doing well
thank you Lauren I think the lion has
got the right idea there just taking a
little bit of Chilton's afternoon
probably got a very nice of you and may
be nice wouldn't underneath being high
up in the tree trying to pick out some
parents over yeah I can hear them
calling I can't quite see them the
reason why I wanted to show them to you
is because well they have a similar sort
of nesting to a lot of them like we were
talking about starlings before spry can
hear them from the distance they sound
like a rusty metal gate that you open
and there are whole nesting species like
the starlings as well as the as the horn
bulls as well as the rollers or nesting
in tree cavities and the woodlands of
the Savannah and majority of the
cavities are created by woodpeckers in
their search for grubs as well as
barbets creating the nesting homes
okay well Tristan seems to be on the way
I know everyone has let us know or me on
Twitter that there is a lipid on the dam
cam and also to give you the news there
Justin used the wrong coms not to tell
me on the radio Kirsty instead of you
steady use on the way so there we go
Justin's in trouble for using wrong coms
I'm a knee jerk he's done it wrong not
in trouble he just has to have something
to drink later
so anyway Tristan is much closer to the
dam he has been checking around
Gallagher for Columba while what we
think was possibly to lumber and well
it's a nice time of afternoon for
Columbus who've come out to have a drink
obviously and that's why it's important
for us to check watering holes it's not
just birds will come down to drink but
many of your sort of prey animals will
come down and drink and muzzle in the
middle of the day and sometimes you'll
find leopards in the middle of the day
if the heat is not too bad
so lumber obviously being much younger
than her father the Duke he waits until
that's very cool before he starts moving
around she's just got a bit more ants in
her pants I suppose and also she's
probably quite hungry so we're gonna
head south from yeah I'm just gonna poke
our nose into chick trap because it's
quite warm have a little look-see at the
dam see if there's any elephants maybe
that are popping out because it'd be
wonderful to see some elephants and then
we'll see if we can follow back up on
some cats costs do you want to know the
colors are all changing and when will
all the green be gone well the grasses
themselves if there's no more rain they
are just going to get drier and dry and
dry up and go through a sort of dormancy
stage but if there's some rain just like
you've got to water the lawn and your
house you can keep your grass from from
going brown last you add a bit of late
rain in April but the trees as well they
will start losing their leaves as soon
as the daylight sorts of reaches are
certain there's like a daylight limit
that sort of happens and then a lot of
the trees will start losing their leaves
the trees that keep their leaves our
journey those that have got very good
access to the water table so combination
of change in daylight hours as well as
change in water depth could potentially
lead to the trees losing their leaves so
when you do find trees with lots and
lots of leaves and them still very green
it's a very good chance that that plants
has got access to the water because
essentially if you keep your leaves on
that the leaves are a pump pulling water
from the bottom but if you don't have
water to pool then the leaves are
basically going to dry up and they're
going to cause damage to the plants
they're gonna start pulling water out of
the plant that it can't afford to lose
so if you've ever run a pump dry you can
do it's some serious serious damage and
so in trees don't want to lose any more
water and drop the leaves it's one of
the things that they're do art yeah okay
well we're just gonna hit a straight
down here and see what's going on a trip
to earth for a little bit but some nice
Lac there yesterday who knows what could
happen today but I mean so I'm David
Gibbs you has founded the sausage tree
pride correct
I mean sting just close to any water
hole in Africa wilderness will always
bring some good luck and a few minutes
ago when I was telling you hopefully
when you're going to come back to me
we're gonna see the fish we might be
lucky to have caught up with a sausage
trip right and I have to clap for myself
and for all of you because you're all
going to see this beautiful setting
together this is the whole family of the
sausage trip right well I would say the
whole family - of course the bow is the
mayor not here but where we are I have
counted three females and 10 Cubs and
you can tell they have everything they
want because the green grass behind them
there has lot water so if they would
need to drink that's where they'll go
the injured and is such a beautiful
sport notion where that's one look I
won't go for a drink or where he is
headed to and thank you very much I'm
sure all of us will need to toast a
glass of juice
later in the day look at how the green
the grass is
and of course he might be going to
investigate something there and maybe
bump into a frog who knows now got three
females here and this particular pride
you know for those of you who do not
know it you should have five females or
two are not here with me and I'm sure
there's somewhere now one interesting
thing I have to tell you I've been here
for the last I would say what five seven
minutes and I'm smelling some chaos that
I cannot see the wind how settle down
and to pick up the exact position of
that carcass
it's very difficult so what I've done is
to stop here I also stay in the shed
just like these cuts and slowly if wind
is going to pick up I am going to
identify where the smell of the
carcasses coming from but I'm sure there
must be a killed somewhere while this is
very very good news here for us in the
morrow tranquil killer but I think
Tristan have even better news this good
news today's been a good day so far
already I mean Lauren's got her lines
David sweat the sausage free pride and
Mia's little Columba as well she's
decided to come for an officer noon
drink so thank you to all of you that
let us know via the damn cam that she's
around um it certainly has helped us be
able to find out the problem that we
have is that there are guests in the
lodge and so I can't really follow her
if she goes kind of left words so we
needed to kind of head up that Bank
towards that thickets on the other side
and whilst she's kind of standing like
that I'm actually gonna try and get
around quite quickly because it's
difficult for me to cross to where she
is now I've got to go around the other
side I was hoping that she was gonna
drink a little while longer but it seems
as though she's decided she's that
enough and there's lots of squirrels
shouting at her and there's gonna be in
parlors and bull de beasts that are
about to also charted her and so that's
why she's going to hit off in that
direction but at least we've found us
like we was saying just now it was
definitely her tracks we were following
earlier and
it was just unfortunate that we couldn't
really go because of guests otherwise I
think they would have been able to
tracker all the way through and probably
found out quite quickly but it's okay
and this we have all of you guys to help
us Hudson so it was a team effort
this afternoon let's just quickly get
across the wall she's got a tail up
that's gonna make kind of following her
a little bit easier from a distance
we're just gonna go onto the road she's
heading straight towards the road on the
other side and from there it's gonna be
probably a really long process to follow
because it's quite thick
indeed James it's true she is filling
the pan patrol that husana left
especially cuz it's a TV day today so I
mean you know when we did TV last time
for next year we had lisanna pretty much
at the damn most TV shows and so she's
filling that role I was saying that I'm
sure a few weeks ago we were talking
about this and I was saying that I'm
short telomers gonna be here a lot this
winter
given how high it is and so hopefully
that's gonna be the case hopefully mom
doesn't push her away and we get to
spend lots and lots of time with the
little princess over the course of the
next few months particular if she's
gonna be at the damn cam wasn't that be
nice now she should be here
there's his work heart's exactly where
she came she might have just gone in
Lane one of these worried tickets given
how hot it is I mean she's had a really
nice drink she's not extremely full
which means she's not going to igneel
but she should be somewhere here so the
sins are saying to me she came between
there think if you got in parlors right
here so they're gonna help us if she
moves past us
you know the impalas will start to shut
and they'll make a lot of noise which
we'll be able to help us find her but I
think she's probably lying in one of
these thickets yeah given how hot it is
today is the edge of the water scene so
she came here somewhere we are you
little clamber I think she must be
inside here since
hmm there's a squirrel alarming I see
where she's gone I say the Impala is
behind us will help us because if she
moves in that direction then she should
be able to kind of see her
did she come this way since she did no
straight yeah okay so she must be here
somewhere I just gotta find her she's in
one of these little thickets I would
imagine did you go little Columba it's
amazing how you can be right here and
can't even see them gives you an idea
she's still walking okay so I believe
okay so she's still walking towards the
drainage
then there's the impalas are shouting
now so have they seen her yes they have
issues there okay so the kind of half
wish is not which is good the impalas
are barking which helps us be able to
find riches or this year's number you
are moving far too quickly for your own
good here so she's straight in front of
us now so at least we got view of her
which will help us yes yes impalas we
know well then you saw her okay back in
parlors it's going to try and avoid all
the little Tam booties inside yeah drive
over them
of course Columbus taken the most
difficult route through yeah she
couldn't have just gone up towards the
road could she still CEO since last time
I saw is walking here oh there she is
there okay
all right like I said this should be an
interesting story because it's gonna be
thick it's gonna be dense it's gonna be
difficult and so while we try and catch
up with her let's send you back across
to the cute little sausage overload that
is in the Mara Tristan I trust you very
much and I'm sure - lamba is not going
anywhere because you're going to cards
up we have pretty soon me I'm having a
ball I'm having fun because my cuts are
not going anywhere and I do not see them
going anywhere for some three good
reasons number one their initiate no
cuts you want to move out in the heat of
the day unless they do have to - as you
can see the green cross behind them
that's a natural spring and there's a
lot of water to drink from and of course
number three as I said earlier I can
still you know smell the carcass I can't
see it as yet I've tried to reposition
myself I'm putting my nose out I'm sure
you have seen how Lions oh how some of
the animals won their dream what's
called grimacing and they put their
noses up just to smell the fertility
sometimes of the females that's what me
and Bunga drain and I've been doing that
for the last couple minutes we have not
been able to really wear that carcasses
but I'm convinced it's easier
somewhere now this particular point have
a nursery school another school of
different ages we've got about 11 cups
Calcagno asking why are they sleeping
well it's rather hot here when we
started it was mid 80s but his very
height and very high as a centigrade
we're talking about almost a 30 degree
Celsius that is too hot
many cards many cards some turkey of
lions cheetahs leopards Jaguars in
general wins heart they want to stay in
the shade you know lions because they do
not climb trees like their pots they'll
always choose a place like this but also
let's look at the bellies
you can turn the Bailey's a fool they
have had some good it and of course if
you're fool you have drunk enough water
to quench your thirst or to adjust to
protein they're witten what is the next
thing you do for lions it is typical
just to go flood but look at the cabs
up and down pretty active and still
showing they are not really tuned up
just like the adults now this plate
pride I've got two mares have got two
pride males that you call the owner on
your pike
I haven't seen them I do not know where
they are and this one cup there you see
I guess he's just being curious and
trying to be different from the others
hello there I tried to bite some sticks
to strengthen your teeth maybe or
strengthen your muscles possibly are you
turn
well everybody's sorry about the
technical issues you experiencing there
we've popped on to Chitra to come down
to the watering hole of course and look
at what has materially mysteriously
appeared in front of us it looks like it
possibly the uncle Homer prides but I'm
not 100% sure I'm trying to get to some
nice identification features there's at
least two young males possibly even
three young my house which is a little
bit strange but they are looking very
very full very full indeed there's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten of them and well they've eaten quite
well and they are very hot and very
uncomfortable in this afternoon sunshine
some of them are sporting a very black
lips from drinking the very muddied
water that is now what remains of it we
are watering all so you see there's a
young male he looks like the normal and
Kahuna a young male there's an off to
the left which also I'm not sure
everybody we're gonna get a closer look
at these individuals and see if we can
find some characteristic features I
thought on the left there and you can
see one young male and there's another
one in front that's definitely a male
let me see by the neck and then that
seems to be it just by the look of it I
thought it was the man gained email but
I haven't been able to see under the
tail yet maybe I am confused completely
but we've just arrived in the sighting
that individual that we were looking at
looks like it was lying in all sorts of
weird wet stomach content or something
Oh in fact that looks like a lady that
is one of the old girls that just looks
very scurry gali been lying in out of
the water or in the stomach content of
some sorts we really don't know
hopefully it's water as I'm sure if any
of you've ever come across a stomach
content it doesn't smell very good at
all at all
ode to stomach content that's what
Kumari did the other day with the
Buffalo dung
he liked to mask his very smelly
the smelliness of himself okay so I'm
guessing at some groomer bride just from
what I can see the man gained email has
normally got a very characteristic sort
of face to him did you see Darby water
buck suddenly realized that there's
something over here
the Woodend is wafting over to them in
that direction okay so yeah this right
okay that is the oldest line s so very
good there she is with that very badly
injured hip and a stop that's looking at
much better much better condition and
then it was all those many many months
ago so everyone is confirming it is them
google map rider now when you see this
hip of this female it's always a very
easy way to identify the prod sometimes
there's some other characteristic
features but it always takes me just a
few more minutes to do so well very good
it seems like we've all found ourselves
some cats this afternoon and these guys
are enjoying a very nice bit of shade to
provide the dieppe on the side of Chitra
watering halt provided by a very nice
big jackal berry well it seems like
surprises are on the offing today and
Tristan has got another one
it's indeed is very surprising because
our beautiful little girl who you can
see has found herself some shade
has given us a really big surprise in
the form of a really big meal now in the
background there you will notice there
is a fully grown male Impala that seems
to be her kill now I went past the
Impala we spotted it just as she was
kind of approaching and it does look
like it's got bite marks on the neck so
I assume that she managed to bring this
down all on her own which would make it
the biggest kill that we know of that
she's managed to bring down these know
at the sign of any other lipids here and
the fact that it's got black marks on
the neck tends to suggest she didn't
just find it dead so it's a fully grown
male Impala which is a huge huge huge
huge meal and milestone for a little
Columba now whether or not she's going
to be able to keep it at a highly dot
I'm almost 99% sure that she's going to
lose it to Highness at some point this
evening but isn't it incredible that our
little princess is starting to really
grow up and is managing to catch things
the size of adult male impalas it's a
huge huge meal for her well done girl
now one day you Hutton bothered so the
fact that she kind of walked sort of
back in this direction intended suggest
that maybe she had some sort of a meal I
wasn't sure but I was thinking there
could be something around here um but
the fact that she's brought something of
that size down is quite something and I
know a lot of you are saying wow it's
pretty impressive isn't it she really
has kind of stepped up and managed to
find something incredible so I'm super
happy for her I'm glad that she's
managed to get a nice big meal hopefully
and I know I say this in in a kind of
bad way yeah well maybe some of you
might say in a bad way but I actually
hope ting gana arrives and I told you
why in shacks you just referring to this
is as you say this is ting Ghana and
hyena bate and in exactly ilyich she
wouldn't mind Tenggara arriving because
he would have the strength to hoist this
and you'll find that he'll kind of eats
and you'll keep plump at bay for a while
but eventually she'll actually get a
meal out of it far more than if the
hyenas are rather I mean is gonna pull
you off this in
two seconds and completely chump that
done last night we had so many hyenas
moving around in this area and who knows
maybe you know she's been losing kills
in the last few days because our hangars
look as though they have been kind of
put on a sausage machine and being
force-fed for huge chunks of meat
because they've all been fat and full
over the last two days and we haven't
really been finding carcasses so I
wonder if maybe little claw Lamba hasn't
been feeding my resident I in a
population and so it would be good for
her to have a little tingle or not
little big thing on her arrived to be
able to waste it into a tree for her to
be able to get some sort of food out of
it at some point oh she's going to have
to learn what her brother learnt in the
form of being patient and waiting for a
scrap or something for the iana sleeve
behind and in grab that and take it up a
tree the problem is is where it is at
the moment really is not anywhere near a
nice tree for her to hoist these are all
tiny little trees that are around her
and it's gonna be very difficult for her
to drag this really anyway I mean that
killed probably weighs more than she
does almost double what she does
actually if you think about it so she's
got a lot of kind of work to do to be
able to actually move it she's eaten a
little bit
what's a huge amount as yet so I'm
hoping that at least tonight she'll get
a really good kind of feed out of it
before she sort of loses it if the
hyenas do come and they do sort of get
to this point the other problem that
she's got unfortunately is that where we
situated is right next to a road we
within I don't know 15 metres of a road
and we know that the heiner's like to
use roads as they move around in the
sort of um in the evenings so they're
gonna come up and down these roads and
for them they going to be able to spot
that really quickly you can see kind of
where the road is behind me so this is
the road that runs and oh is it hyenas
are gonna move around from here given
that we have a dam behind us over there
and there's another dam straight up this
road on baffles hook so it's kind of a
thoroughfare for many animals that walk
along here and the chances of her being
able to actually keep that is gonna be
quite slim but I'm super impressed I
mean it's a serious serious meal for any
lipid to bring down and so she's done to
super well and as she gets a little bit
older in life we're gonna find that
she's going to perfect the arts of
killing these guys and being
he will get strong enough to be able to
put them in the tree now
this little cat is going to probably
have a really good nap and rightly so
she's obviously been busy too through
the course of today whatever you see him
go don't see anything behind us but
anyway she's gonna have a bit of a nap
in the meantime there let's send you
across to you Steve and in Colima prior
to her doing much the same
welcome back to church everybody where
it pays off to check the watering holes
just as you some of you spotted a lumber
on the damp camp
Tristan was able to find her and one
we've managed to find the Oklahoma pride
just chatting with someone on the radio
and it seems that the McCormick pride
ate a young juror off sometime this
morning and there wasn't here it was a
little bit further away but obviously
they've come here before drinking very
very good well they say the sign of
Independence for a leopard is the
ability to fully kill and take down a
male impala and well Columba has done
that it's not her first male in parler
that she's caught but the surest sign of
being independent is then being able to
on your own
hoist that animal into a tree so as to
secure your food resource there's no
doubt in the first few male Impala that
Columba catches she's probably going to
lose them to either her dad or two
hyenas
who no doubt will follow her around they
can smell her there know exactly who she
is well this is great we've got a couple
of the young lions walking around the
oldest lioness dive is right at the back
they're busy having a drink don't know
why she walked all that way to go and
have a drink she's looking very very
full some space for water we thought
maybe they were all gonna start leaving
because two got up and started walking
off but have come back into the shade
this is the only real shade to be found
Kamilah know how it's all a line is if
it stands on its hind legs well I'm
gonna have to just double-check that for
you now there's definitely a measurement
in my book it gives me sort of that they
head to tail of a lion I'm just gonna
double check it so that I don't make a
wrong mr. I don't say it wrong here for
you because it's important that the
information they give you is accurate
but I've seen photos of lions standing
with their hands on the shoulders of
people and they stand taller than a
human but obviously it's difficult to
say exactly how big they are cuz
obviously people come in all sorts of
shapes and sizes but Lions for the most
part are pretty much the same sort of
size so I'm just gonna double-check in
my book a few comment 67 one second okay
so average height 120 centimeters so but
that's from the shoulder that's from the
ground up onto the shoulder so that is
not it's not in this book my other book
definitely is got ish oh maybe not but
lots of different resources to check the
actual length of an animal give me one
more second
okay so shoulder height doesn't actually
give to you in this book so definitely a
lion standing on my shoulders on its
hind quarters and its legs extended with
its paws on my shoulders would stand
taller than I would
so more than six feet they're very very
big and it's they are very very powerful
and so lion that could stand taller than
me in the weighs twice my weight you can
imagine what they can do running at
enormous speeds jumping on to very very
big prey animals
she is a very thirsty girl and although
the uncle humans are looking a little
bit active right now I think it's mainly
got to do with just the fact that
they're Bailey is very full they are
water back abounding in the surrounding
areas they will have an idea I think
that the Lions are here don't perceive
them getting too close there's one on
the dam wall itself off to the left
there that's spotted these lions and at
once they come down and drink
we saw the kudu yester they're coming
down to drink and they were a little bit
tentative I don't know where the uncle
homers have come from in the night
because where we found their tracks just
now was just up the road here on the way
into her from the main road Gary main
where we come from but where they came
from it's very hard to say lions will
walk quite large distances in search of
food and then they can spend a few days
in that place once they have caught
something just for digestion and for
catching up on some much-needed sleep
okay well Lauren had some interesting
into action not so long ago with giraffe
and a dead baby I think she's got a live
a fully grown one at this time let's go
see if there's any drama unfolding that
side yes I do these giraffes are very
very close to me right now we have four
female giraffes that are just absolutely
stunning they were actually on the road
so we had to stop and it's definitely
worth stopping for there's just giraffes
everywhere right now I don't really know
why I was frightened cuz I don't have to
they're more than relaxed with us here
but it's just ah it's just wonderful to
stop we're having so much luck with cats
today we are actually on our way to
other cats which is why we did leave our
very sleepy lioness but don't worry we
will return back to her cuz I don't
think she's going anywhere for some time
but we just don't even stop and
appreciate these absolutely gorgeous
animals now robust reading I've spoke
about their spot pattern it's difficult
when I say spot pattern but there's not
really spots but that is what they call
it when they refer to the patchi's I
guess you could say patchi's pattern
actually the calf's whether they're male
or female inherit part of their spot
pattern from their mothers not the
entire thing but they inherit quite a
large part of the pattern of patchi's
spot pattern from their mothers so they
will have an identical area on their
body that's exactly the same as in
mother's isn't that incredible now
they're really close to us like know
sometimes giraffes can get a bit nervous
but the cars but these ones are just
completely relaxed I'm quite happily
feeding
[Music]
ah my father's favorite animal is
giraffe we grew up with giraffe
paintings and giraffe ornaments all
around the house and I think I can
finally admit that I see what he's
talking about giraffe girl seen the
belly on that one yes actually quite a
few of them have huge bellies and
there's one at the back and of course
our view is completely blocked now the
third one in that row of three her belly
is so swollen I'm beginning to wonder if
there's a pregnancy there two of them
huge huge huge bellies and giraffes can
either said to eat up to about 34
kilograms of leaves and foliage perdy
now that is about just over 70 pounds I
think that was my attempt to quit maths
in my head so they eat a lot of course
look at the size of them they will need
to eat a lot
you can get a glimpse of that black
tongue they are just a third eating it's
extraordinarily striking when you see an
animal of this coloration and it's pure
black tongue which contains so much
melanin which was thought to originally
protect the giraffe from the Sun of
course our skin has melon in it as well
but it's probably just used more to make
the tongue more rubbery if you like the
melon in itself will make the tert the
tongue turn black it'll be thicker
stronger and more rubbery in nature
which will indeed protect it when eaten
sort of shrubs and fishies with thorns
or anything like that but a lot a lot of
the theories do go that it is to protect
it from the Sun but I personally and
this is just my personal opinion
I definitely don't buy that 180 scene
there's such graceful creatures and oh
they really really are and although you
know they do tend to walk quite slowly
they can gallop up to extraordinary
speeds when they want to it takes um a
little while to get going they're not
the fastest animals to get going but
once they really get into that gallop
they can go anywhere between 50 to 60
km/h which is extraordinary for this
animal and they really only have two
sort of movements to dekes it's either
walking or galloping no not really able
to do much other than that but light
alone they're just fantastic and if if
James is able to give us a beautiful
view of this one from behind you're able
to see the way they likes come in at the
knees now in humans I think you would
maybe refer to that okay it's off again
I swear the animals know what we're
saying maybe this one would be good
James this one here so you can see the
knees pains in and in humans a condition
like that I guess would maybe be called
knocked knees
something along the lines of that and
the reason the giraffe is structured
like that it because it very regularly
puts its knees together in swatters
position so when it needs to bend down
for foods bend down for water and of
course with females when they are given
birth so that is why the legs do taper
in like that and they almost has a knock
means effect hello beautiful look at
your awesome corns they're lovely and
unusual they're almost joining in the
middle there I don't know if it's just
the way the wind is blowing their flus
if you like or if they are actually
bending in towards one another
either way it's stunning now I think our
giraffes are very soon going to move off
and we of course have a mission we are
going to look for more lions I won't
ruin the surprise just yet but we are on
a mission and why are we do that we both
send you over to David his little
sausages I am sure I am sure you know
Lauren will be getting possibly more
lions as I said earlier that territory
she is in she has a possibility of
either getting they all aloneness or
they you know pride and having said all
Aurora's that has reminded me that I
still got some work to do on my song to
control the oral pride after they lost
her some Cubs a few weeks ago well my
layouts haven't done much but I have now
vaguely been able to identify where the
carcass is coming from not very far from
where I was able as well it's nice play
there between one big boy cub and that
youngster there I've been able to have
an idea that it's coming from my right
hand side not exactly that I have seen
it but after listening or just smelling
careful not even listening from the wind
I have been able to know where this
fellas come
my guess is that all this is a buffalo
that these lions brushed down and my
guess is could be two days ago or three
days which would translate them being
here for the next three days which is oh
very good news for me
the whole pride is about nine days going
to ten since I last saw them but three
days ago is very lucky to see some of
the Cubs on top of a tree that you call
the butcher nalli tree no if the phone
they have had enough to drink the only
moment you cease teaching there yes just
because of the little disturbances over
the treasure from your flight apart from
that sleep snooze and maybe dream and
maybe not sure oh no what they could be
dreaming about now the mail hasn't come
to join them and what it wants you maybe
at one point is to try and confirm well
that keys and find out if there are the
two fevers that are not here there now
this pride the last we had a count we
counted me and Bungay 11 cups and Bungay
is the camera operate with me I'm sure
now Tristan has been able to catch up
with slobber
let's find out at the latest of course
we have we're having a to go to very far
but she's not feeding on the carcass
which is in some ways quite entertaining
because look at how little she is mixed
to the size of this Impala it gives you
an idea of just how big this meal is and
they really is going to be zero chance
of a hoist thickness into 'try when you
see her standing next to it you realize
just how much bigger this Impala is in
what she is at the moment but good on
her for managing to somehow pull this
down I'm trying to see if there's many
like there's a struggle marks and things
like that's and it looks like there are
a few sort of hues and things like that
but doesn't look too bad be quite keen
to go around the other side and
Neville's check properly to see what's
going on but either way she's going to
tuck in and have a really good feed now
and she's going to try and probably get
those innards out you can see it's fresh
fresh fresh she's just starting to open
it up now now Nancy how would she get
that up a tree
well brute force is part of its middle
lipid is an incredibly strong animal but
it's initially what she'd have to do is
if she had any chance of this being
taken up a tree she would have to get
every bits of those internal organs art
um completely disemboweled this animal
and then she would have to grab it by
the sort of throat and then sort of
havest I would imagine a tree how would
she have killed it sorry not how would
she get it up a tree well how was she
killed it's quite simple she wouldn't
lay in the bush waiting and then as the
Impala came past you would have jumped
onto grabbed it and try to get it her
mouth either around the throats or over
the nose and then hang on for dear life
basically that's the only way to do it
and eventually the the sort of strength
of well this cat just cooing and holding
on and then just hanging by that throat
the Impala gets more noise orcid and and
you know she can then start to suffocate
it but it would have been a massive
struggle for her to be able to bring
this down properly she would have
probably got dragged around quite a bit
at first often what will happen when
antelope of the size get taken by
smaller predators and you see it's a lot
with cheetah is that the animal almost
locks its legs the antelope kind of
gears into this leg lock and they kind
of spread their legs as though they
don't want to fall and they try and kind
of pull their neck away from the
predator to try and kind of somehow slip
parts and then run but and if the
Predators can get their cause in and can
get their teeth in then generally they
have enough strength to hold on and then
it's just a game of waiting it out and
waiting for this animal to die what
surprises me with this is that win and
Impala gets killed it's not enough quiet
affair and not so much from the Impala
that is dying or dead it is from the
rest of the impalas that are in the area
they generally go absolutely crazy when
one of their own is grabbed and the
alarm call lasts for that much longer
and I don't recall hearing in your long
today of him parlors and we're not far
from the launch at all but maybe I
missed good maybe we just didn't hear it
because of the wind or something like I
don't know but either way she's really
done well and I'm super super impressed
with her it's a serious meal for any
Leopard
let alone a leopard of a year-and-a-half
who's her size you know she's still got
a lot of growing to do but it is a kind
of proud moment when you see them with
these bigger kills now her mom is a
lipid that has brought down many an
antelope that is far too big for her you
mean because even when she's pulling
with all her might that carcass is not
going anyway so she's gonna have to do a
lot of work to kill her to get this kind
of eaten down to the point where she
could actually put it somewhere but her
mom was is lipid that has brought down
her fair share of rather large items as
well as her brother Tambor he's managed
to bring down could you young kudos and
you know ton D she I've seen her bring
down a fully grown could do car which is
massive as well and probably a but kind
of relative in size to what we're seeing
here so she's grabbing for his good
stock and eventually and like I say when
she's a sort of you know prime this is
going to be par for the course she'll be
going after many of these male impalas
particularly this time of year as the
rut starts we know that the rut should
be starting and and ready we seen sort
of signs of male Impala chasing one
another and I wouldn't be surprised
that's what's happened here is this was
purely opportunistic she probably was
lying down in the shade and just resting
and in parlors came past and she just
grabbed one and was able to kind of pull
it down is what my guess is with this
but we'll see I mean it's very very
fresh to his most smell whatsoever
from this Impala so it's not something
that's died yesterday or this morning
and has been baked in the Sun for long
she must have killed it fairly sort of
recently the softs mean there's lots of
hoof tracks from where they were running
close to me I'm just looking in the sand
next to the car so maybe they came and
came running through chasing each other
and she managed to the in grab it and
has started to feed it quick though
isn't it amazing the strength in such a
small cat often we kind of think about
how strong wild animals are
so a lot of your stress that hyenas are
gonna come in shortly
well no not now and it's too hot there's
very few hyenas that will be moving
around right now but come sort of six
o'clock we're going to start to see
hyenas coming and in no doubt they will
take it but remember when there's a
carcass hyenas actually not too worried
about the leopard they'll run in and
they'll grab the carcass and they'll
start to feed and we've seen it
countless times with lipids when liners
rob them as they'll come in they'll feed
they'll chomp in and eat as quick as
possible and hopefully what's gonna
happen in this scenario is it's not
going to be one of the big girls that
are out here so it's not gonna be a
pretty or a Corky that comes here
hopefully it's one of the boys back
Sokka who will have a feed and they'll
eat until they cannot eat anymore and
they become like little barrels and then
sometimes they'll walk away and that
will allow Columba to come in and grab
whatever is left and that's normally
kind of some of the carcass which is
basically probably what we want is we
want her that to have the ability to
actually have some sort of bit of
carcass I mean this is just way too big
for her to to hold on to no matter what
happens here even if it's tomorrow
hyenas will find it and take it away
unless of course her dad arrives which
is also always possible he looks around
these areas quite regularly and so maybe
he'll come in and be able to take it and
I wouldn't be surprised if the highness
do come in the commotion he arrives to
look at the size of that poor neck or
it's got a kind of tears all spread
massive florien she's not only eating
the skin you see she's just broken
through the skin now and to start
feeding on the meats over the rib areas
and what you'll find is she's going to
open that kind of cavity arts and so
she's eating is a sort of membrane that
runs between the skin and the meat and
then there's a sort of Bailey section
and once she opens that she can then
start to pull out that stomach area and
get rid of all of that stomach content
which will be fermenting heavily inside
then starting to expand and swell and
then she can kind of get rid of that and
get to the choice so two organs inside
there and this is very common to see a
leopard start like this where they kind
of open up a flap along the rib section
and the belly area and then they kind of
go down towards between the legs and she
has actually eaten from the ramp already
it's difficult to see the way that she
is at the moment but
there's a little section of the ramp the
tail area where she's actually eaten
away at some of that now so I think
she's just trying to create a hole and
then try and kind of get rid of any of
those internal organs which is it smells
good and sometimes they also just like
to eat a certain section and they they
go for it from there might find she's
also struggling a little bit to move the
carcass around and so this is just the
easiest spot for her to be able to
actually feed and put in sort of
sustenance in and that means that you
know she's able to actually kind of get
some food from there rather than
fighting was trying to roll the carcass
and get between the legs and all those
kind of things if she wanted to feed off
the sort of rump area what she could
just be in that kind of mood where she
just feels like ribs you never know it's
a good thing though which is nice is
that all the alarm calls have stopped so
there's no longer squirrel shouting at
her no longer birds so she's going to be
vitally important the longer that
there's no alarm call in this immediate
vicinity the better it is for her to be
able to keep it all the longer she'll be
able to keep it well she got herself a
rib in the last one
no gun girl she looks quite smitten with
herself doesn't she quite on edge though
as well and I suspect that she knows at
some point there's going to be hyenas
coming and so she any sort of noise or
movement as you see her kind of whip
around and look in check what's going on
well are we going to stay and see what
happens I'm sure it's going to be an
entertaining evening with our little
princess and so while we waited send you
across to the Inca Huma pride who have
already feasted like she is now and are
now sleeping away they hard-earned meal
thing oh you've got too much chocolate
than you think you can deal with and
every time you hear a noise you think
it's someone bigger than you come in to
steal it it that's what's going on she's
caught more than she can deal with but
she still wants to have as much of it as
she possibly can
well that all the sly nest was drinking
for the longest time I don't know why
she took so long to drink I didn't think
there would be any space and now this
other youngster has gone down to drink
they're much closer then with the other
one went to this is just down the path
from where all the Lions are lying down
and they are looking very uncomfortable
everybody there's all sorts of panting
going on here as the diaphragm is pushed
up as high up as it can into the chest
cavity by their very full belly of baby
giraffe
and what a treat the guests of chitra
Lodge and just look over a hundred yards
or so and they can see the Lions on the
other side of the watching hope from
them this is wild country everybody and
if the hippos in their watering hole
that didn't say it enough for you a
pride of lions sleeping on the other
side I surely will
don't forget everybody we are live and
interactive would love to hear from you
this wonderful Sunday afternoon from
wherever you are in the world center
your questions and comments hashtag
safari lava or throw them in on the
YouTube chat a streamer bearing in mind
I'm focusing on lions at the moment so
have any questions pertaining to t uncle
Huma pride send them through to me mg
you want to know a very important poo
story and indeed hippos actually
defecated in the water there's a couple
other animals as well birds and fish
will defecate in the water and
essentially you want to know if that
affects the predators and I don't think
it would at all what the poo does do is
it increases the nutrient component in
the water which can quite often lead to
build ups of algae which quite often
take out the oxygen in the water and can
lead to a bit of a fish die-off it
doesn't necessarily make the water toxic
for other animals to drink but it
necessarily just takes the oxygen art
which is important for the fish albeit
you find it quite strange that water's
got oxygen in it
it does indeed and if you had gills
you'd be able to breathe under the water
but with watering holes and with rivers
the movement of water is quite important
but the problem is is in a watching hole
like this there's no exit plan for the
water the water just gets lower and
lower so decreasing in in density
decreasing in in the amount of it and
with the increase in hippo organic
material in there there will be an
increase
in the chemicals as well as a decrease
in the oxygen an increase in the
nutrients which what happened last year
with 10 Ghana cameo is feasting off of
the fish so he would have fed off a fish
that would have probably starved of
oxygen oxygen starvation but there
wouldn't have been poisonous for him to
eat
but this tricky there are lots and lots
of things they can go on with water as
well but naturally archer hippos are
actually an important sort of driving
force in the ecosystem but unfortunately
when you get watching holes that starts
to get very very low and dry out that
increase in organic material can offers
often have the opposite effect well that
line is has had a fault and she's not
come back to rest her head on her pillow
mmm okay so everybody wants some updates
on the uncle Hummer cabs and well we're
just having a look at the lionesses yep
I haven't yet been able to identify
amber eyes amongst this group so we've
definitely had the oldest Linus we've
got the two young males the maenge an
email as well as the one uncle who
mermail the lioness that flopped down
there is one of the youngsters she's got
no memory glands visible there's another
one there that's hanging on to the male
she's got some mammary glands but not
really visible the one off to the right
I think that is not the oldest one on
the far right there Darvish is the only
one with any sort of visible memory at
the one on the right more a little bit
more that one there's the only one who's
actually physically got any sort of
mammary gland growth at the moment but
there's no suckle marks and it's very
hard to tell because their bellies are
so swollen from food that if they were
cabs inside there would be very hard
oh sorry Darby look at this young male
over here the inside of his leg yeah
there we go and kind of in the middle of
your shot now inside of his leg there is
a very nasty looking wound over there
Wow now that could have come from a
buffalo horn from another lions claw
very hard to say but how that doesn't
make me feel very happy
it looks very painful and that is the
maenge an email as far as I'm aware I
saw his face earlier was this something
gained email now they swapped around I
think I'm getting very confused the my
getting email is it got a little bit of
a longer face and when they're looking
at you it's quite easy to identify the
difference between the two males but the
man gained email has recovered an
enormous amount of condition his even
his tail has grown back
so unless they both sit up and look at
me I find it quite tricky at the moment
to identify the two of them both got a
very similar development of a mane so I
can't tell you for certain right now I
think that might be the Oklahoma young
male are out there but we will keep
watching when he lifts his head I'll be
able to confirm it for you but when it
comes to Cubs of the pride I don't know
we haven't seen them in I haven't seen
the uncle humus in ages now where
they've been they've been wandering
meandering all over the place there
hasn't been any reports that I've heard
of of them having any Cubs they were
most certainly mating when I came back
in December and January so we've got the
oldest lioness it's one and then we've
got another one there that's - I haven't
seen the one with the purple eye yet so
there's at least two adults yet possibly
three and I don't think one of them is
amber eyes so I know that the purple
eyed lioness was mating I haven't seen
her here yet but very tricky she's got
actually open your eyes and look at me
to be able to see that but the yang
stirs are all melting in to the adults
they're all getting quite big now we're
looking the same sort of size
projects alpha you said the lions are
found at the beach of the migration
to ambush well I don't know what animals
would come close to them right now but
definitely there is the potential for
someone to sneak up on them the water
back that Beach Boys beach ball Oh
indeed they have indeed eaten all of the
beach balls their bellies are very very
round I'm sorry I didn't get you a joke
there project I've had to apologize
please do forgive me I was thinking to
Dave earlier because the one old lioness
came and set down around in front of us
you got such a balls of a belly I was
rounding if it would be possible to just
like sort of squeeze it and where it
would go would have come out come out
the mouth or would you be has a line
ever eaten another line to try and
access the food in their belly I mean
there's so much meat in there there's an
entire animal it seems inside a lion's
belly that it would be an easy sort of
thing to do wouldn't it if you're a big
male lion and you wanted food just beat
up another one and steal the food from
them steal the beach ball from their
belly well an animal who by the end of
today is going to have a belly
twice the size of the uncle Homer pride
once she's finished who male Impala or
at least had a piece of it let's go and
see how much Columba's loving her meal
well Flemish certainly will have a belly
probably three times the size of she
manages to consume all of this and it's
nice not that she's actually turned it
so he can see the kind of face of the
Impala which is probably a good
indication of how she actually killed it
so when I first saw it on the neck I
thought there was blood but it was just
a shadow but if you actually look on the
nose of the Impala you'll see that's
where she must have grabbed it because
the nose itself is completely kind of
chewed up in some respects and you can
actually see the bite marks where she
got a muzzle over the muzzle of the
Impala itself and it must have just hang
on for dear life from there and
eventually that would have suffocated
this Impala to falling over and
and kind of dying from there so that's
how she's killed it it's not by the Nick
she managed to get it by the no is
instead which is good it's a good
technique it often do you do it and a
lot of lip is will use that technique
because it's much quiet the animal
doesn't make nearly as much noise if
they can get it around the muzzle now
she has eaten through kind of the rib
area and and expose those inner organs
and as there was quite a lot of sound
and things which is probably quite good
that we went on here cuz it was a bit
sort of the way it is a bit rough I
suppose in some respects it's not very
nice when you hear all of those squishy
sounds as the kind of internal organs
starts spilling out of the Impala which
is a bit macabre site so nice that she's
already done it and you don't have to
witness all of that and she's now slowly
but surely kind of just going through
the ribs you can see she's so spackling
with it and she managed to drag it a
little bit where she's kind of turned it
and I'm sure she's a lot happier to feed
where she is now because not quite as
much in the Sun as she was to start it
Kathy I've never seen them use their
claws to tear open a carcass on purpose
so I have seen hunts where lines and and
lipids have crabs and animal and in the
process of struggling they've kicked
with their back legs or grabbed with
their front legs and the speed of the
animal causes a massive rook to take
place and we see it sometimes with
things like zebra we had that really bad
zebra injury here that looks like lions
so you know you kind of see that more
than anything else but in potentially to
open a carcass no I've never seen it
it's not like they kind of flick a co
out and then they surgically cut it open
that's was something that is reserved
for Disney I'm afraid Archer it's it's
the canines that do pretty much all of
the work the the paws and applause
generally are grouped to be able to pull
it and open it and shift it and move it
and then from there they'll be able to
feed on it she see how wary she is
definitely learnt that feeding and
having her head down causes noise and
she needs to be a lot more kind of
careful when she's on a carcass that's
all traits that she would have learned
in time when she was with
mother and feeding on all the various
caucuses and since she's been
independent she probably would have
learnt it even more so given that she
I'm 99.9% sure she's been robbed a few
times by our resident hyena population
and so she will be learning valuable
lessons all the time when this happens
and the fact that she's killing big
animal circuses
means that those are only going to
happen more and more and eventually it
will drive her to learn hearts of high
skills but I'm afraid this is just too
big and too heavy for her she's got no
chance I mean we watched wasana struggle
with something of the size and he was
double if not triple the sort of weight
that she is or maybe not triple but
definitely double the way she is and he
struggled with big animals like this so
you know she's got a long way to go
before she's ever gonna be able to waste
that up into a tree impressive though
either way to be able to bring it down
is still pretty impressive and it bodes
well for the future of little Columba
and her sort of part that she's going to
play in the sabi sand lipid legacies
that we have Archer what bits of your
grandmother no mother in her she's able
to bring down animals like this
basically what she's doing is she's just
kind of slowly but surely just breaking
open more and more of that sort of
cavity and you can hear a little bit in
the distance it might be a bit tricky to
hear but you can hear it crunching the
skin every now and then and eventually
that's gonna open up far enough for the
stomach to come on so you see the
stomach is starting to expand and swell
after through that rib cage so
eventually it'll be broken and far
enough that that will come out and be
easily pull able and she can just kind
of grab it and squish it off to the side
and be able to actually kind of get rid
of all of that and open that carcass out
properly amazing how surgically they do
it you'd think that her kind of eating
like she was earlier it looked like she
was just kind of eating off the rib
section which you can see how it's
exposed that stomach area and so if you
are squeamish probably not a good time
to be looking but all of that behind her
head is the internal organs and that for
standard stomach that we know ruminating
ruminating animals have so that's all
gonna expand and kind of be able to be
pulled out
they might find she'll go after a few of
those organs now I think though she's
more trying to open it further so that
it's easier to actually get rid of all
of that stuff and then you'll find that
they start to eat the sort of kidneys
and the heart and the liver those are
all firm favourites of most cats so
we'll see if she actually gets tucked
into those and it's amazing to watch
this kind of feeding process compared to
lions and and wild dogs and wild dogs
this would have been long gone by now
and the lines to the ink uma pride came
across the simpler they were the way
they would have eaten it would have just
been everybody would have ran in and
they would have just been pieces going
all over the place and it would haven't
have lasted more than sort of five
minutes or so whereas you know for her
if she could keep this would be a
probably a three to four day meal so it
gives you an idea of just how much more
methodical and how much more kind of
careful lipids are when they feed in
comparison to other predators that we
get archaea same with hyenas they also
destroy this carcass in a few minutes
it's not going to take long if a few
hyenas arrive here
very cool
one of those proud to moments that you
have when you've been watching a lipid
for quite some time and you always think
what's the biggest animal she can kill
and me obviously speculate to me don't
know but is the first real evidence that
we've got of her bringing down a fully
grown male Impala I don't think we've
seen her feeding on a fully grown male
Impala by herself
have we I know we've seen her with a
fully grown female Impala when she was
quite young which we thought maybe died
of natural causes but this as far as I
know is the first fully grown male
Impala we found her with by herself
might be mistaken but I think it is
Firefly you say you guess the days of
worrying about it independence is over
well not necessarily and the reason why
is that she's still young I mean she's
not a territorial individual she's still
got a lot of kind of work to do until
she becomes territorial but from a point
of view of feeding herself yes we can
stop worrying now I'm pretty sure she's
more than capable of feeding herself
sure you know she's hardly been with
tandy over the course of the last two
three months and she's absolutely in
perfect condition so I don't think we
need to worry about her from that
standpoint but she still got a long road
from the standpoint of intruding males
females and her carving out her in
territorial space in order to become a
successful adult lipid and that will
only really show in in a year's time
when she reaches sort of two and a half
three and she's starting to actually
mate and those kind of things then we'll
have seen her really kind of get through
it and then we don't have to worry
nearly as much but of course any lipid
is some worry throughout their life that
they get sort of caught by lions or
these kind of things I mean we know it
happens one of her brothers in fact was
caught by lions when he was about four
years old so he you know was already at
that point where he was completely
independent and looking after himself
but you know these things can happen so
it's a little while to go for elemental
we can be kind of rest easy in the
knowledge that she's
completely okay and managed to and I've
sought to sell fat
now do you need to jump on the radio
because I need to be able to get hold of
the guys they're busy calling me so try
and get hold of them now Derrick sorry
we just live at the moment I'll just
come up and we working here your vehicle
she's got a cool model bumper yeah um
right so we're gonna just keep this
vehicle in in the meantime let's send
you back up to David and see how his
lions are faring well
Tristan very good job with tell Amadeu I
decided to come out of the car and show
you how tall the grass is but then
Bungay who is the camera operator the
metadata do something different and he
told me I need to show all of you
my boots with a zebra boots and I have
these boots because as you've been
saying a few times the long rains in
Kenya are just about to start and you
have to be in nice boots like this you
do not get stuck definitely I will not
get stuck on a tumin mount is the Tamil
mount
well my main purpose of coming here was
to show you a very small tree this tree
here that happens we used to call them
acacia trees but I think the name has
since changed and we call them the phone
trees think was just too hot had my
sunnies on I think that has gotten
better so we call them now phone trees
now this is a new one that's just coming
up this is a termite mound and we know
Tom I do not eat anything green
so what Thomas will do will always eat
anything that stuff dead grass stuff
like that so anything that will grow
here will not be touched by the termites
and hopefully if this tree is going to
be a big tree the roots or the trees
itself will be used as a pillar by this
termite mound here over the termites
under here no this is a baby thorn tree
now I want to show you what I call a
fully grown or an adult
yes running another acacia tree or palm
tree which is this one right here I do
not know when but this tree here was
brought down by the elephants in general
found trees do not have what you call a
tap root they do not go so much down in
the ground their roots and remain on the
surface and it's very easy to bring them
down and one thing we know about the
palm trees any place you see thorn trees
growing especially one particular
species that you call the fever tree
it shows the water table it's very high
now this is where the tree was
originally and the elephants are the
ones that brought it down and I think is
just a smaller swing or touch of an
elephant trunk just to bring the whole
tree down now what happened here is
they'll get the cambium if you look
carefully there I'm gonna show you
you see they have cheered a lot of
branches and they get the can be on the
very top or what just surrounds the
branches and then after that they left
one side of this tree especially the
left side you look carefully the leaves
are still green and out of experience so
long as there's one route that is still
touching the ground this tree will keep
growing regardless of having been
knocked down by the alleys I do not know
how many alleys were here but I'm trying
to imagine it must have been quite big
hard now as much as I'm still smiling
and celebrating having seen the sausages
I just won't remind everybody the height
off the grass in the morrow now this is
where we are I'm about five something
and you can see this grass is this tall
and this type of grass is what we call
the red oak grass or tomato tree Andra
and I'm imagining if the rains continue
they'll continue growing currently my
guess is this is about two meters long
well we are always very careful at a
time we'd come out of the car
we'll always investigate to make sure
there's nothing dangerous we can deal
with rats we can deal with mice but of
course no snakes so whatever number of
days the elephant stayed here all hours
stayed here feeding on this you can see
the trail they left behind and it's only
the elephant's that you'll be able to
bring such a huge tree down and of
course leaves such huge chunks on the
ground well I think that was a good
break for me to stretch because the
sausages are not going anywhere they are
going to remain whether you are unable
to steer beach flats why don't I give
him a bit of a break and I was give them
a bit of break because I will go back
and I will get them right there I have
to jump back in the car and then rewire
myself so that I can hear what caste
would want to ask me cus is the director
ready to show off in the arena control
and think you Bungay and I hope that was
not bad because in the morrow in general
we always tend to remain in the carbon
get you happy we move on excellent
ok
thank you very much those boots you only
get them in Africa so anytime you come
in a dream safari with us you know
either in Kenya or world earth
expeditions as you call them you'll be
able to get the same boots
if you come from countries which rain a
lot now I don't want to take chances
what you need to do is just to get
prepared so that if the rains come we'll
be ready to go on a path but will always
carry some nice raincoats and maybe two
extra layers she did get cold so that we
are able to keep warm now my plans for
now is to go look for something else but
an of some time when t cools off I go
back to the sausage lions and I'm sure
Stephen want to tell us about their new
comers
it's everybody we're still here and dave
is doing a wonderful job of getting the
facial expression of this lioness while
she has a poo you do not want to see
what's happening at the other side you
really did not oh I just looked it is um
it's quite quite horrible in fact
there's no ladylike behavior amongst
lions I've seen them stand up sorry I'm
trying not to dry rate right now I just
looked at a very very wet and dribble
eat poo happening there and I think they
was quite keen to film it will you take
there's no ladylike behavior it comes to
lions I've seen them stand up and
urinate and defecate right where they
stand
yeah that does make things quite awkward
when you're in a sighting for a few days
if there's a buffalo or giraffe carcass
because they will just let themselves go
right where they're standing well if you
get any of that on your wheel each you
don't want to do that that's probably
one of the reasons why I eat in the den
the youngsters are so keen to come and
smell the car because of all the smells
we bring in so we've now got a nicer
sort of look at the two males they're
just here on the right-hand side they're
both lying flat and the one on the right
is the monk any male and the one on the
left is the uncle Homer male now very
similar but there's a difference in the
face and the eyes among any males got
these yellowish just sort of eyes
whereas the Olmec males got more Brown
sort of eyes but there's a difference to
the face which I can't really explain to
you looking at them right now but when
you see them both together like that
there is a difference he's not it's
prettier than my gained email as the
uncle Homer male he's definitely
recovered most of his fur and all of the
injuries he'd sustained with his mange
as the the the bad state of that he was
in he's looking in far better Nick than
he used to
and by all means he is a little bit
bigger then
mermail although his main development is
seemingly a little bit behind and well
that's probably got a lot to do with his
condition it's just like a human if you
are ill and you're not in a very good
way
you're not going to develop as well as
you would if you were in very good
condition so he was struggling him and
his brothers were trying to follow
prides of lions they had a very bad case
of mange and they weren't eating they
weren't getting the nourishment and
nutrients that they required and so that
would have led to sort of a delayed or
stunted development which is what we're
seeing because he seems to be a little
bit older then they won't calm a male
but you wouldn't think that by his mane
so it should be five - yeah and I've
only managed to count a three so there
seems to be two adult females missing we
don't know where they're full you want
to know if the hippos would come out
well you know hippos probably would
still come out they're not too bothered
by lions really and it's adult females
with their carbs it might be a little
bit more sort of weary but a big male
hippo you wouldn't worry too much about
a pride of lions they would have the
hard work getting out of his way but
they might also try and choose a
different path to get it out
they might not walk out exactly where
the Lions are but there's nothing really
to stop them from walking out it would
just be a protective mother with her
calf might think twice about the route
she chooses but essentially hippos have
to come out every night and there is
potential for there to be lions around
an early stage so they have to sort of
take their chances when they leave the
water every night anyway
but I don't foresee these lines going
very far at all if anything they're
moving like a clock in an anti-clockwise
direction as the tree tracks around or
the Sun tracks around this really big
jackal berry tree the shade keeps moving
and we were in a very nice patch of
shade which moved even more towards us
and the lions or moved in to that we've
had to reverse away from the lions who
sooner or later it would have been using
our vehicle for shade there we go
wonderful scenes down here Chitra was
chatting with one of the guides about
what we were discussing before about
them comers and Cubs and he says all the
Cubs have died there's no sign of them
there's no talk of them no one's even
discussing pregnant females at the
moment but then the two females are
missing so we'll have to have a look at
them ourselves and see well anyway Lions
often heralding the approach or the
position of vultures and it seems like
David has got one in the sky or in a
tree
well yeah Steve still there with those
lions because I decided to leave mind so
at least I know you goal is to hold on
and trying to imagine mind will not go
anywhere but I found in this particular
vulture here not sure exactly what he is
doing
of course you can tell it's quite hot
you got cheese or she got his you know
how wings out which is an indication
that she's rather hot and this
particular module is called a
lappet-faced vulture or the nubile
Nubian vulture this year the name for
them and look at her head she's all bare
no feathers on the head for some obvious
reason and why we call the locket if you
look carefully on the head you can see
or behind the head good as you can see
there was some wrinkled skin that's why
we're calling lapid's but if you look
carefully their wings are out just
because it's still another heart here
and it has not cooled off
now this particular vultures in general
will go in twos the very out say out see
they're monogamous vultures it's
comparing them to the other vultures and
why I cannot see they have a member
unless she could be or he could be some
other part I have no idea
no the other vultures for example the
African whitebark vultures they'll
always be the first one to spot some
came this one will always come last at
carcasses trying to get some pictures
for vultures view and show you the
vultures that I would have expected to
help us lead us to the carcass of the
sausage tree pride because the African
white backs vultures and I may move in
flocks something from five 10 20 and I
want to show you how the African white
box poachers look like and you'll get
them all over East African track of
Kenya Uganda and Tanzania so that when
they are Bungay this is the African
white box Fulcher there thank you so
very much
and of course as the name suggests you
see the white patch the
it's the H parts the others how they got
a name so let's leave now as the one we
have here the lappet-faced vulture and
that is the lappet vulture and if you
look at the very back there you can see
the skis the bed wrinkled now in kenya
we got seven ordered course seven true
vultures seven true vultures and in this
particular area this common African
white bucket are corn and that they are
followed I would say in in accuracy they
are followed by the RuPaul's Griffon
vulture which are these ones here and of
course the difference as much as the
African went backwards have this right
here just like the troopers given
vouchers but if you look carefully on
the feathers there you can see lots of
white and black on the reverse Griffon
vulture now vultures we do not see and
we do not know what might have up and
order still around and I'm sure they are
is this from here which is the white
headed Africa vulture certainly open
game and you see that from there is a
female it'll begin size than the male
but I do not remember the last time I
saw a white-headed vulture then we'll
cause we got the hooded vultures and as
the name suggests it's like they got a
hood on their heads they're they're
vultures what we do not have he in the
Mara is a very special and beautiful
vulture that is called full drawing
guinea fowl see that one there no table
toes on that one that one Ted
it was the Egyptian vulture this
Egyptian vulture here is one voice a
story that I have not seen for a very
very long time we're a little bit
worried what could be happening to the
digital voters and have been concerned
of maybe poisoning either by farmers not
sure for a fact but it's like month
months since I lost so many years I
would say since I last saw an Egyptian
vulture well lost
doing about seven vultures there is the
palm not vulture and very difficult to
find in Amara but to me the palm not
vultures got the best call what you're
gonna play for you right now
[Music]
all right funny enough that call is very
similar to the african fish eagle call
and also somehow they are very similar
those two particular big birds of prey
well thank you very much hopefully your
mitch is going to come around i don't
know who as she or he is but maybe on my
way back to go back to the sausages
we'll get the two of you together let's
go back across to tristan maybe to get
an update on - lamba sitting still with
Kalama she's decided to now go and
parker so erased
hidden spot that there is in this whole
area there is this massive kind of nice
open shady spots but she's decided in
amongst the fallen tree is where she
wants to lie and so there's really not
very much of a view from where we are
right now but we'll reposition there's
another vehicle that just left that you
can see the damage that she did and how
she kind of opened it out so you're
asking what she was doing and you can
see how she basically cuts a circle out
of that side of that Impala exactly
where the biggest internal organs are so
let's just reposition slightly and see
what we can do here
it's quite interesting you can see ray
she kind of fighting with this Impala
can you see their sins or was the branch
in the way James have I heard anything
on Tandy and whither she's dinning James
I was actually Rick's and I were just
sitting discussing it cuz Rick's was in
the siting with me and his tracker Mike
we were kind of talking about it and we
were saying we wonder if it's the case
because she's been super abusive of late
and really not easy to find answer
Rick's and I was saying I think maybe
it's that time of the year to go and
just check all the likely den sites that
she likes just to kind of check around
you never know I mean it might be that
she's not but there could be a
possibility that she has been she gets
skittish in not see to it which it's shy
like this we don't see how much she's
normally up to something so we'll go and
try and check around they told me though
they had her tracks this morning on
Central going eastwards towards eastern
boundary and then finally and rusty said
they were out this morning too and they
had tracks on Jana at North so that area
there's where she spent a lot of time
the Columba and could very well users at
the insight she has she apparently was
you put there when she was a cub and
Rick's was telling me about it so we'll
see well go and scratch around will you
use our best weapon which is heavy and
as well as the drone and trying to see
what we can find it be interesting we
did quite something if she does have
Cubs because then her and Ken yeni on
exactly the same time schedule
theoretically tell amber and little ones
or which is in Kenya a nice previous
daughter they are roughly the same age
and then if you kind of look if they
both have Cubs now then they're getting
to have roughly the same age
little ones once again which is quite
interesting but we'll see I would be
very surprised though if Tandy does give
birth it mean that she's been mating
with a male where none of us have found
her which is possible I mean tortured is
a big place and sometimes not that well
utilized but it would surprise me that
she hasn't been seen any she's relaxed
enough to kind of find her mating in the
noise that's made with mating lipids is
that that we would have probably found
them here if they want Jim is so not
sure James I mean it's it's a it's a
plausible theory and the last time I saw
her she was day
definitely very very big whether that
means that she was pregnant or just very
well fed I'm not sure but I would I
would like to kind of find her and just
try and see her really nicely I mean I
haven't seen her properly yes or briefly
the other day but I mean seen her and
spend lots of time with her this year
really so I would love for her to kind
of show up wouldn't it be nice if she
showed up this evening that would be
quite cool to see if she kind of is
pregnant or she's you know still looking
for a mate be an interesting kind of
scenario unfortunately they were
probably gonna have to leave the
sighting for a little bit and there's
quite a few other cars that do you want
to come here to us now so we're more
than likely gonna have to make a bit of
space just now but was it you for a
little while longer James you say
crossing fingers yes and no in some
respects because if she has deigned and
then she's keeping it very quiet which
is gonna make life ice a tricky we're
not gonna be able to at the stage we
don't have any idea where she's using so
it'll be a kind of a few months of
having to try and find her the best
thing that we can hope for is that she
has a kill somewhere where she can spin
sort of two three days and we can
monitor movements because that always
gives it away immediately if they have a
kill big kill and she moves from it and
kind of goes back and forth thing we
know definitely that she's got to the
ones or we can at least see if she's
really massively full and if she's
starting to lactate - anything like that
that's what our best chance is I just
hope that she hasn't given birth on
torture would I say that even though I
know we have access to tortured but our
signal there at the moment is just so
poor with all the vegetation that it's
very difficult for us to go into any
places that Tandy likes to walk there
she likes certain drainage lines that we
get zero signal at and so I hope that
she's not dealing in that side because
it would be a bit of a shame if we don't
get the same ability to watch her grow
up like we do like we did with little
clamber minta lumber was spoilt in that
we could spend so much time with her as
a little cub really we're very lucky in
many of the sightings that we had and
even then it wasn't as good as some of
the Cubs that you've had I mean if I
remember how it was with Jionni Jionni
was a daily occurrence and seems like
she'd deliver in her cubs are pretty
much the same as all so let's see let's
see how we go I mean you is always
hesitant to say for sure that an animal
has Cubs or anything
when we haven't really seen the evidence
but it would be nice to have little ones
around again if she does have Cubs in
there's no females really Archer that
has accepted suppose Keshava that has
any ability to have Cubs cuz they'll all
have little ones by the end I mean if in
Kenya he's got this before suck female
she might have given them a ting she's
done she'd do tianni Sibley Tandy she
has won so it'll be the boys will have
nothing to do they'll be roaming around
her being very feeling very sorry for
themselves in many respects right what
we gonna have to do like I says there's
not really much space for the cause I
think what are we gonna do is just give
others a chance and we'll come back a
little bit later and we'll see what
they're up to
and in the meantime that sends you back
across a to Steve and those very snoozy
20 cats in coolness well come back
everybody then Koo whom is having it
done too much heads lifts up every now
and again because there's a little bit
of a wind that's picked up and I think
they're just uncomfortable you know that
and you got such a full belly you want
to sleep it off but you just can't quite
find at the right position so I think
we've managed to identify amber eyes
amongst this group and there she is
there in the middle of the screen that
one there Davi with the leg up to the
right maybe there's amber eyes there a
little bit of a nick on her on her right
yeah and she is a magnificent individual
so she's the one who had we believe at
least two sets of Cubs last year but
they didn't manage to survive if you go
down her body you bail to see that she's
an adult mammary glands are enlarged but
there's no sort of suckling happening
there at the moment so the one other
female that we sort of identified
earlier that we was talking with one of
the guards here he said that she
possibly had Cubs but they didn't get
very far
that didn't last very very long at all
we didn't even know about it
so uncle homers not having as much
success in the way of rearing their cubs
in this last year or two as have the
sausage tree prides but it comes and
goes like that you get stages of growth
and development within a pride and well
they are ten individuals yeah there is
one and missing the Tala mighty male
would have been the 12th I don't know
where he's gone to he's been chased off
but where he's disappeared to do we have
no idea you tick she wonder for
Cockerell could kill an adult lion well
it depends on the size of the crocodile
of course but yes most certainly a
medium-sized or big crocodile like the
one they call Boris here within Chitra
could most certainly kill a lion and the
reason they could kill it not
necessarily because they are stronger
although they are it is the fact that
they drown and the lion so that is how
they would kill the lion they wouldn't
necessarily suffocate the lion on the
throat or anything like that it would be
the ability of them drowning the lion so
anything can fall prey to a crocodile
and a lion is not non exception to that
although you don't often hear of
crocodiles at taking lions but it is and
it has happened before in the past well
there's this youngster doing she's got
all sorts of things on the mind it's he
I think she's going for a bird
it's a bird somewhere here that's all I
can make out as a hippo by the water
maybe she's being very brave you are
being very silly if you're gonna go and
try and catch a hippo out of the water I
can promise you you're gonna fail
acquisitiveness inquisitiveness of a cat
is often what is going to get him killed
isn't it
well the curiosity some would say
and now she's lost all interest all
together so by the middle of this year
all of these youngsters and that one
corner pride are going to be around the
age of three sort of June July time and
that is the sort of time when the
females will start becoming a
reproductive potentially reproductive so
it might increase the pride growth as
well the oldest lioness probably may be
a bit too old to be breeding now we know
the purple eye lioness was mating we
don't know where she is I think she's
the one that is missing and amber as
well she's got a horrible track record
of late so maybe it'll be up to the
youngsters to help the uncle homers grow
but anyway Loreena seems to found some
more lines up in the Maasai Mara
I wonder who she's found there are lions
everywhere now I am the first to admit
this is not a great view we aren't able
to offer roads here however we have
located the river pride or what we
believe to be the river pride there very
flat as all lions are at the moment but
just because of exactly where we are
this is prime river pride location so I
assume I think I'm almost 99.9%
guaranteed that that is them now the
reason we've came here and the reason we
picked so much effort and to get in here
is because there's still a mystery of
the Cubs a huge big question mark over
the ole ole ole o river pride dispute
and which Cubs got killed so we can't
see any Cubs at the minute because
they're so flat but if it is the river
pride they will get up I've spent quite
a lot of time with them recently they
will get up and I really do believe they
will get except once it just gets that
but marginally cooler so I'm gonna make
the gut decision to stay with them I
want to see how many are here and if
there is any Cubs because as we know
Cubs unfortunately got killed during
that dispute with the dead hippo and it
was automatically thought that it was
the older Lalo's I honestly thought it
was the ole ole ole ole Cubs but
apparently
now this was not witnessed by us but
witnessed by others the ole ole ole ole
female was actually seen but one of the
other females was seen with Cubs again
hmm how can that be if they all died at
that sighting so the recipe of debate
was at a river pride cop that was killed
was it all alone oh and really we don't
know what we need to do now is spend
time with these animals and actually try
and figure out who has Cubs and who
doesn't so sorry to confuse you all but
this is exactly why we are here it's
very frustrating that we can off roads
however the Lions will get up and I'm
more than sure we'll get a better view
of them at some point
Jackie's saying there's a lot of
theories and yes indeed there is I
obviously cannot vote one way or another
I cannot confirm but I do listen to
everything everyone is seeing here and
it would be good to get some answers and
unfortunately in order to get answers
you do have to spend some time with the
animal even if they're flat as pancakes
like these ones are now you do just have
to sort of have patience wait and solve
all the mysteries and get answers to all
these theories it was a horrible
horrible day for Pat during that
incident and naturally we did see two
cubs dead we weren't able to confirm the
third one but it was just thought or
assumed should I see that the third one
also died so it is time to really
unravel that mystery and we have found
the river pride so that's exactly why
we're going to stay here it's just very
frustrating that we can get closer so I
do apologize for the below average views
of them but we have watched a sprite in
numerous times trying to hunt warthog
stalk Impala they are quite an active
pride so I hope the wake up soon
I think mrs. Anna is asking about
finding things in Namara and is it more
challenging I think that was the
question
well the Mara is just so vast it is just
a huge gorgeous beautiful landscape you
can drive for miles
now you you do always see animals
without a doubt you will never drive and
not see anything
you will always at least see some Impala
I mean it runs us here I've seen
Thomson's gazelles some buffalo warthog
Impala and that's just scanning this
area here so it's filled with animals
but in order to find them sometimes
you've got to drive a little bit far and
that does take time whereas Juma's a lot
smaller a lot more convinced and it is
far easier to drive around whereas here
if we hear that there's an animal
somewhere away in the distance then
indeed it will take us quite some time
to get there so it's not necessarily
more challenging mrs. Anna
I just I would say is more time
consuming so one more update while we
look at almost update we did hear of
aged cheetah this morning that was very
very close to where we live just at the
bottom of the escarpment and it was from
the hyena research program they told me
there's a cheetah and it turns out it
was a female and I haven't had proof yet
but I think my heart tells me it could
be my queen bee so tomorrow my plan is
to absolutely find out who this cheetah
is so we're gonna try and get in a bit
better position here and maybe see some
more than lion bottoms and see what we
can do but for now we're gonna send you
back down to Steve
well it is a Sunday but we'll give it a
cat today nonetheless lions lions
leopards everywhere and well you're very
lucky that you musta Devery buddy this
lioness in frame right now I think is
the youngest of the adults and well she
stood up and released her bowels at
Birth David myself could not contain
ourselves we both nearly voided all the
contents on the side of the car it was
very horrible is something very very
disgusting about lion poop directly
after they've had a meal because all
that comes out really is just a slurry
of blood it's not very nice to see so
I'm gonna leave it there not talk about
it anymore before the image of it comes
back to haunt me it's a beast laughing
on the back because she even got some on
the back of her leg and then she
urinated and it's just lines this is
nothing there's nothing elegant elegant
about the way that they behave they it
table manners or something to be desired
I suppose they do love each other very
much but they really don't have any I
remember em bars actually every time
I've been with um guma prod amber has
always steps up goes about 40 50 yards
away does a business and then comes back
to the pride the rest of the private on
the other hand so far has not been as
accommodating
there she is panting heavily as the
diaphragm has pushed up into her chest
making the lungs much smaller now she's
very very pretty lady
tools of the line trade are there
I'm terribly sorry about the description
of those visuals everybody just had to
get it off my mind I'm sorry that I had
to indulge you in such a horrible affair
but I'm just also quite fortunate you
quite fortunate we went live at the time
because our cam ops have a tendency to
find these things then she Darby yeah
hey David she asked me why doesn't the
big documentary is and all the big
documentaries out there ever form
animals
booing and I said well it's not
something people really want to see
hello Mau Mau you want to know about a
lioness it was really badly beaten up
I'm not sure when did this happen and if
it's an old story of the injury on the
back hip the female is right here in
front of us the one in the front to the
frame their hip is looking very much
better than it used to but I'm not sure
what lioness you're talking about that
got beat up I'm not sure if I missed
something please if you'd elaborate or
maybe a mercantile Madhavi do you know
anything about a lioness that was beaten
up sorry ma ma I'm not very sure what
happened now I honestly haven't seen the
Houma pride in it must be about a month
now
since I've seen them
and I don't foresee them going too far
this evening
okay so Emma's saying there was a
lioness from a couple months ago at a
very bad eye and seemed to like she'd
had a beat-down well I'm not really sure
I haven't seen it and if anything I
haven't noticed any individual here with
any injuries apart from a number of
ticks on the eyes or the old wound on
the back here or a couple of afresh cuts
and scratches on the faces and heads of
the Lions as no dart were from the
feeding that took place earlier today
when they're caught themselves they
young giraffe but the size of their
bellies I'm going to assume it was a
medium sized giraffe and not a little
baby because they're all rather full get
a good 50 to 60 pounds 70 pounds in
their belly at one time and well if you
divide that by 10 that is a very big
animal
nice to see them though everyone is
saying these are such cute lines cute I
suppose you could use the word cute one
thing I remember when I went to the Mara
was that the Lions were looking in very
good nikki apart from the old lioness
with the injury their fur and everything
was looking great and then while I was
aware that was that when the whole monk
gained email sort of story happened all
the mange and those those two followers
on and then the three follows on and
then just the one guy and since that's
happened I came back I remember I when
was that in December and I they really
don't look great I mean their fur it's
all it's all monkey and there's
definitely signs of a mange on them in
all different places but you know they
are a healthy pride of lions but they
their coats and well their pelts
whatever you want to call it I'm not
looking as good as they did before I
left in August September August they
were looking a very very very good Nick
well oiled and just beautiful and since
there are Vil of the manganese they're
all looking a little bit scrabbling I
wonder if any of you out there agree
with me and tell me if I'm talking
nonsense
but I remember being quite noticeably
shocked when I saw them when I got back
in December maybe that's just because
the Mara Lions just got such good coats
then just look they look much better up
there I suppose or so we'd come out of
the migration where the Lions have there
been eating left right and centre
whatever one they wanted to is down here
then coomer's scratching around trying
to find whatever they can find
and also the woodland is quite dangerous
we were looking at the one young male
earlier that big injury on the inside of
his leg that is in fact the Inca home a
young male and I'm not sure what
happened but possibly from a a wooden
stick or a log or some sharp object
while hunting or maybe a piece of zebra
wood or something is the injuries to
happen to lions and sometimes the
injuries could be debilitating but being
in a pride and allows them to follow
each other around and to benefit
the efforts the pride can put in this
old female here a testament to that okay
well we're going to stay here with uncle
homers as long as we possibly can and
while we do that let's go up into the
Maasai Mara with David nothing is left
for sausage reprise stupid think you
you're one of the luckiest a naturalist
today because I don't know when the
newcomers were thin last so that's the
very good news that you've been able to
get them make sure you do not go
anywhere stay with them as long as it
takes
now I left the sausages as you all know
and I thought I'm going to bump around
to show that could see anything else and
the reason I did that cause it was
rather hot and I could tell do some
crackers because I kept smelling
something there I never saw the carcass
I will just ice won't you believe it
still there and I will go back because
by the time I go back either
the wind will have picked up and it
should be a lot easier for me to get
hold of the carcass and of course once I
get the carcass I'll be able to see
maybe as I'm eating now I have come here
is because I've got some wind sorry I'm
not doing that three-point tun because
the road is it's quite narrow I might be
doing end up doing about ten point tonne
for good reason because there's a
drainage on one side and drainage on the
other side I've come here because I got
some wind somewhere that there could be
a spotted cut just like what we have
with Tristan so I am now going to
investigate and find out if it's there
or not but I will not tell you as yet
what cannot spotted cat I'm talking
about but I'm sure you all know if
anything the only two spotted cuts we
could be talking about in a big size
either a cheetah
or a layer party or did I give it away
not really I just said supported the
cartridge exactly like all Tristan has
but I am going to investigate whether
what my friend told me is true in the
village I come from we have always had a
proverb
and and what I'm trying to say is we
have a proverb from where I come from
when you're taught of something and
you're not sure you'll only see a bad
you quiz part to you something so until
you're hundred percent you never commit
so let's slowly move and we're going to
be getting to that particular area
and find out if it's something or not
Jane good question there and you're
asking are there any animals Jean with
no predators Jane I'll say I highly
doubt who doesn't have a predator well I
might say maybe hi now oh it's
high-energy I might even talk of all
just Jane who eats vultures so as far as
I'm concerned most of the animals that
you got yeah Jane got predators I'll be
counting to you a field but our guest
maybe that do not have predators as soon
as you find out if we are able to get
this surprise now I'm gonna show you the
camera and find out exactly where this
cat is unless it's flat in the grass
there and I think he's oh yeah I see it
is way down in the grass not sure the
Bunge will be able to get it but this is
the surprise I'm talking about and very
initial place for him to be and I'm sure
you can all guess who this is
they still they can see the spots or you
can see the results and you'll be able
to tell me who this is
that is how they hide not sure to say
whether that's how they hide or how they
camouflage it's almost impossible just
to see it but my guess is this is a
leopard and I'm sure you can tell from
the markings there results there
but whoever saw it must have done some
magic work to have seen it you remember
I was telling you of that swallow a
proverb we have in the village if you're
not sure of something 100% you do not
commit yourself so what you say you say
a man showed me something so even if
he's not right you're fine but you know
so what I'll do is try and reposition
myself and see whether we might get a
better look because where he is totally
hidden and my guess is this could be the
Shepherd telepods let me see if I
reposition myself we may have a better
look
when we will preform
that's impossible that's watch em in the
final control who has taken over
directing the show this is pretty crazy
cover flood because whoever sweaty or
Nicky boy or you happy that butterbur
Ribbit's I have a game
alright let's have a look and see that
we'd be lucky to see it
one guy thinks he got a better vision
they're not the very best but I'll say
is a lot better than before
so my guess is this is the chef at gmail
this is his territory
and he has been in this domain for quite
some time the last we saw him he had
some kill and he had some elin baby on
top of a torture tree and that his like
watch two three days ago so ideally five
days ago five days he will go without
another kill which would be fine but in
between you know they catch up smaller
birds they could catch guinea fowls they
could catch Franklin's so many bastard
could catch like where exactly he is I
would not confirm 100% it's him but my
guess is this is the chef at tree mail
and see the heat you can see the panting
a little bit warm hot day but that's an
impossible position to spot this cut I
want to double confirm with my friend
how he saw it because the grass is that
high in Romania when I was out of the
car the closest spot two meters long and
in 20 might in this layer but the bodies
has to be about a feet about 10 inches
in thickness and braying there in that
grass is like a joke Aldo I'll do one
more round
so you can see the head part of it and
then I'm sure I'll be happy because I
really have to thank my friend who so
this leopard who call it for me because
I do not know whether I would ever ever
see it
very good not sure heid Tristan has left
to lumber would you Tristan explain to
us what you've done
we have for the meantime it's just
giving a chance to everybody else to
view her where she went and lay was very
difficult and so there's any really
space for kind of one vehicle to see
nicely so we're just letting everybody
else roll through before our TV show
starts a little bit later but the good
news is that there's a couple things
that are happening by the sounds of it
these tracks of ting gana coming
straight towards where the Lambo is and
so we busy just doing circles around
just trying to see if we can pick him up
wouldn't that be funny if he does arrive
given we were talking about it it's not
surprising if he does given his
propensity to find carcasses so we're
just kind of doing some loops just in
case he pops out somewhere close by and
it makes himself known and so that's why
we kind of hang around in the area that
also sounds like there's a lioness at
twin dams which I have absolutely no
idea where she would have come from but
she's also around so I don't know if
Steve if he has to leave his lines and
he can go and check that out as well
yeah as a beautiful bird of prey in the
tree seems like as good a time as any to
stop and have a little look so in the
dead tree I want to just double check it
looks like a young Marshall but let's
make a hundred percent sure what could
it be a brown snake he called no brown
snake eagle by mistake sorry I was kind
of not looking very well well that's a
horrible call no teacher stand slap on
the wrist but yes hunt snake eagle is
what it is um it's because of the way it
was sitting like that it had that kind
of little whitish crease so that's why I
thought maybe Marshall yeah but it's
most definitely a snake eagle you can
see by that bright yellow eye and the
big round head when it sort of turned to
face us and then of course the brown
coloration is is exactly kind of that
for a brown snake eel very common bird
yeah we see them quite a lot this
particular one we see fairly regularly
it bounces between sort of where we are
now and a little bit further towards the
the west and kind of flies around and
follows the Milwaukee for the most part
that's where it generally kind of hangs
but you'll see it on sorry either side
and always sitting in big trees like
this these big sort of dead trees are
the perfect place for a bird that relies
heavily on its sites to be able to spot
creatures that move around in the grass
and that are not actually that easy to
see and so you find that they'll sit
there and they'll watch and wait and and
as soon as they then spot something like
a snake moving they know if they go and
down they come and they grab whatever
snake it is and they'll go after any you
snake really it doesn't matter how
enormous it is they have a few additions
and allows them to be able to kind of
stay out the way one is element of
surprise and try and hit the snake in a
place where it can kind of disable the
snake and almost break its spine with
those talons the second thing is
obviously they lack feathers on the
lakes which we can't see from this angle
but that allows into these heart and
kind of scales on their legs which makes
it much harder for fangs to penetrate
their legs Jeffrey have you ever got
footage of them not sure Safari live we
might have actually in the Mara seem to
remember the one Thomas I saw it and I
think David has seen it before as well
contra member if it was returning the
Pedro were not alive when I got it bad
David's had it's a I think David will
Issac one of the two has had a sneaking
who grab a snake I've seen it many times
but I don't know if we've got any
footage from Jim I can't recall any of
sightings from myself I'm just trying to
think no the most famous footage to kind
of come out of this area with regards to
this is footage that was taken on little
Gary took a cut line of a snake eagle
that went after black mamba and they've
got hit by the black number and venom
was injected and then Tambe and tandy
arrived and so you had two leopards a
black mum and a snaky all embroiled in a
sort of standoff with one another so
that footage is pretty insane and shame
that person a kegel it obviously got
nicked by it or something the snake
managed to somehow damage its wings
because we found it there that often
still sitting panting lying there with
no snake or lipids and and was kind of
just lying there unfortunately right so
well our bumper the sundae continues as
sounds now Steve has decided to get some
spots of his own
well thank you very much what an
afternoon we are having if it was not a
cat today before the second cat today
today everybody and we have found the
queen of Juma's daughter could shava
potentially the father was a hula hoop I
only saw once back in January last year
February last year before he made his
disappearance and she's just hanging out
yep in the long grass on dry so Chitra
is providing for us wonderfully today
and you might ask how do we identify
these and leopards and well it does take
some practice everybody I'm they're
identical and you can look at her now
they're looking at the top of three
spots above her whiskers can you see
that there are three spots are just
behind her nose the top line we call of
them and the spot pattern and she has
got three on the left-hand side and
three on the right hand side we have
managed to see them already but it did
take me a moment to to identify so could
Chava means scared to be Chava
in Shangaan means to basically right not
to be scared of something
you've scared of something and I've
never noticed her to be scared of any
seen her once before I'm on the border
of trap and Torchwood Becky what a
drive indeed isn't she gorgeous look at
those beautiful eyes
he's also got quite a prominent sort of
dark patch underneath her right eye
there that's one of the characteristic
features as well you see it's quite dark
just another art I
and there's some other identification
features that I haven't yet quite have
started to figuring out but you could
see by that last shot him that she had
three and three that she was born in
August September of 2014
makes her almost five Lepidus in her
prime and that Andy used to hang out a
lot here on Chitra and then she must
have made space for couch oven and move
north spending more time and rumor and
now she's making space for column button
though she's moving more east the life
of a Lepidus is really hard isn't it
making space for your children to move
in to take up a residence
Kathy in Ohio we believe she does have
one I haven't seen her but I know Taylor
last year was very lucky to be able to
see her child with her youngster I have
yet to see the cupboard don't know where
she is I think it was a girl last ah
last I heard
better this is only the second time I've
seen Keshava and
so yeah November last year and she had a
cab
don't know what happened if it's still
around it's been ages since we've
actually found or being with a leopard
on chitwa but I know someone we could
definitely ask that Tristan and the
leopard was prepped and he would
probably be able to tell us for sure
what's going on with this lovely young
cat and all she's a very pretty they see
the camouflaged so everybody you quite
concerned about her proximity to you
that won't go Hummers yes I mean she's
about five minutes drive away but
there's also a dam that separates the
tooth so a young lip but like this
doesn't get to five years old without
being quite wily in there able to climb
trees so don't worry everybody leopards
Liv arch yet with Lions Lions come and
go I mean we saw it in Ghana last you're
walking along and sending the Evoque a
male stood up for a mincing on its own
okay just hooks around went up a tree
for safety it is part and parcel of what
they do out here they have evolved with
lions and they have strategies for
dealing with lions obviously they're not
going to try and confront a lion but
it's why they need to be quiet and be
able to be a very alert and
understanding of what's going on in the
bush and then if lions do approach well
let's just jump up a tree so don't worry
everybody she's in a very good place on
the other side from the watering hole
from the Lions and a good couple
kilometers away a mile or so
when it rains it pours and today the
showers from the sky or raining cats
yeah a severe intrusive and that's very
interesting to have you know could have
are pretty close to the new home as they
and I'm sure you know these two cuts are
not friends and I do not think they'll
ever be friends well as it is typical of
lions to go flat
not only nigh on sometimes in general we
say most cats could go flat if they have
the right conditions of everything food
water a nice place to bend in and you
know I'd say lots of good hair look at
now how are the Shepherd similes oh good
stretch why don't you just wake up and I
just have a quick view of your face
please do please do yeah wonderful UHN
rise and shine if you want to catch all
those flies that you think I disturbing
I don't know how many way but to catch
yeah this is a very healthy as I said
earlier a few days ago two three four
years ago he catered for himself
baby eland and he hoisted it over a
tortured tree and you know he stayed
there for three four days eating it
until you know he finished it but it was
run aside when I was watching him eating
it because apparently the mother of that
baby was not very far about 200 meters
just looking on top of that tree and I
think she had a lot of a maternal in
state opposite possibly you know things
would change it's interesting because
this one past month we had had some very
sad sightings reminds me of Lauren and
Patrick Patrick he is the one who stood
to prizefighting the river pride and the
all our pride and we haven't get good in
a proper name for that particular fights
personally I've been calling it in the
Battle of the Mara River and we had two
or three cabins were lost and wondering
whether each Cup came from either pride
or both of them came from the Ola la
Rose and I'm sure all of you know I'm
trying to design a song I'm trying to
write a song to the older Alice just to
console them and the song
is still cooking and you might be doing
that song me and Bungay and then I think
a week later ten days later Lauren saw
this giraffe that a drugged a baby that
was dead and that giraffe mother stayed
there for as long as it took two days
later forty hours 48 hours later she was
still there the baby was dead and she
was dealing with hyenas who wanted to
come and eat that baby it was a sad
moment for Patrick a sad moment for
Lauren and maybe also sad moment for me
three four is a gone to see Anil and
mother looking on top of a tree where
the baby of that island or that mother
was being the world by this male here
that's why he looks in such good shape
and I'm sure he might grow another few
more days without eating anything and we
call him the shepherd tree leopard
because he loves climbing several trees
very good very good so because he is not
trying to be very active I want him to
house a bit of a rest and go back to my
sausages let's find out if Lawrence
Lions could be doing anything
very inactive we have got a slightly
better view of them I must say we did
reposition and we have well you know a
little bit of a better view but it is
getting so much cooler here at the
moment the way there is change and and
of course the Sun is setting so I really
really believe it's not gonna be long
and so these lions do get up now if
James could just do me a favor and sort
of just look over to the escarpment
there you will actually see that is the
escarpment way in the distance where our
camp is so the river pride we're
actually seeing them a lot a lot more
than we ever have because they are sort
of right at Kichwa airstrip which is
exactly where boo Sarah was for a while
at the bottom of our escarpment so they
were pride that we're getting to move
more and more and of course we don't
know all about them but we assume
there's about five adult females from
what we know and there's actually a lot
of young adults well sub-adults if you
like we think between five to seven and
most of them do appear to be males from
what we gather again to be confirmed and
there is Cubs around and that is exactly
what I am hoping to see once they do get
a little bit more active fingers girls
they do get up and they don't just
decide to sleep right through the night
which is what I would do and wake up in
the morning I haven't really hoping we
do get some movement from these lines it
was a big debate to leave that female
earlier who is still looking like a no
lololo and of course we've came here
because we wanted to catch up with this
pride because we're getting to know them
more and more and what is interesting is
if you look at the environment that
we're in right now the airstrip very
short grass perfect for a cheetah
that's exactly why boo Sarah loved it
there's plenty of prey around and it's
short grasses open it's visible you can
see for miles but for lions in almost
contradicts they are preferable habitats
Lions do much better when there's longer
grass and they can of course stalk but
the river pride seemed really successful
here but patrick has actually watched
her make many field hunts I think he's
seen four he probably correct me if I'm
wrong on this
one so there's been lots of failed hunts
by these lions and it most likely is
because so visible if they are stalking
there so very very visible in the grass
I myself actually watched him stalk some
warthog but they seems to be thriving
and surviving here like the flies that
are landing on my face and right to the
other side of us is indeed the Mara
River which is where they get their name
from but I'm sure I didn't need to
explain that to you all so the name
comes from here and it borderlines the
ole ole ole ole territory which is why
they did have that dispute because i
think well from what I believe the hippo
was right on the sort of territorial
boundary which is why both these prides
had a very disturbing dispute actually
but this is very much river pride area
John is saying it should be interesting
as the migration stars yes indeed it
will be we don't know quite when the
migration will star of course as one of
these things it doesn't happen on a
specific date but it is around June July
that migration is expected to start and
david himself has a theory that
migration will start a little bit
earlier this year so fingers crossed it
does I'm sorry I have flies all over my
face I'm not sure why they're so
attracted to me tonight but I'm not a
fan so yes John migration beaubien
traced them with all these different
lion prides coalitions we did go in
search of two males earlier but we
weren't able to locate them so we came
here to the river pride and we'll just
been very patient and hoping that our
beautiful Lions do get up and we can see
some cups with them and start to unravel
some of the mysteries but this is where
we see the river pride constantly so
it's almost not a guarantee but you've
got a very high chance if you come to
this area you will bump into the river
pride the marsh pride are not too far
away the ole ole ole ole pride are not
too far away and a little bit further
ahead you have the Oh wee nose so
there's so many Lions around here so my
lines are flat but I do believe Steve
has a leopard who is on the move
well my cat indeed lauren has just
decided to stand up and to walk directly
towards where that when kuma lions are
lying up how many jerking folks they are
still very far away but she is headed in
the direction of a chitwa watering hole
which is what you would expect about
this time of evening from a cat to start
moving towards somewhere to go get a
drink also looking for unsuspecting prey
they could potentially be hanging around
or making their way to or from a water
beautiful scenes watching this leopard
move through the golden light it has a
very pretty leopard Tandy's got a some
very pretty lineage I must admit
see the the elegant neck couldn't
mistake this for a male I wonder if
she's maybe spotted something underneath
a little thicket to the left not
unlikely we're not uncommon for Franklin
or there's scrub air to be hiding around
in there and they often find out if it's
moving through going from one Bush to
another there we go did you see that
look she gave us day there was a typical
sandy look wasn't it that looked and he
gives she half sir is gives that
it'll look like what are you looking at
indeed like mother like daughter she it
has indeed everybody
you can almost you know when you spend
enough time with these cats you cuz it's
not actually really identifying who
their lineage is who their parents are
then what we gonna see if we can follow
her it's just hit it a little bit
forward desert there's going to be a
little bit thicker it's gonna want to do
so very quietly very little effort
we've got a very nice small car that can
just punch through little holes in the
bush yet such the aerial they're still
got it off to the left over here Dave
Alexson I I'm not sure where that
Columba and Catawba I've ever seen each
other before
I'm not really sure I'm just helping the
other guards who with me here to
navigate towards where she is just over
to my left I'm not sure if they have I
mean sandy hasn't been or spent too much
time on Chitra since the birth of Kalama
that I am aware of
you got her there Davi and see how well
camouflaged she is in this environment
so I'm not sure but I don't think a
Chava would be very nice to Colombo to
be honest with you leopards are
secretive early birds are solitary and
all even Tandy gets a bit annoyed with
her daughter so it's only the parental
bonds between them that sort of keep
them quite strongly you know just come
through to the left-hand side over here
she's laying down now so that's a good
thing I've got a log there Davi
now while we navigate food the thickets
here to try and get a better view of the
slippered Tristan is watching the golden
orb of the Sun sets in the west we do
have a sunset a very very pretty sunset
it's a beautiful beautiful evening it
really is the most kind of nicest
weather that you can have is in the
autumn in the springs of the South
African yeah it's nots kind of what the
word is it's not long for those both of
those sort of seasons but when you do
have them they have produced the most
glorious days and we're talking about
just now it's just how much drier it
kind of looks and how different it feels
there's a very different feel in the air
there's this kind of Kulish wind that
blows the Sun doesn't seem to have the
same strength as it did to three weeks
ago so I was starting to slowly but
surely now kind of go into that winter
period and that Sun was losing its
respite anyway we're back with Kalama
it's gonna reposition ourselves like
Jesus so we can actually see her nicely
as she's still hiding away behind her
laug but we thought we'd just show you
the sunset first we did a little loop
around looking for ting gana saw his
tracks but you know they kind of gone
into a very thick block general
direction is kind of this way but it's a
long way to go until he gets yeah and he
could and they've little bit further
north of where we are but you never know
maybe he does arrive and he gets into
our area and we'll be able to kind of
see him arrive with the little princess
wouldn't that be quite nice
are you having the best time girl are
you playing with a log hmm look at that
face isn't that sweet
she's just lying off to my right hand
side at the moment and is looking very
much like she used to when she was
little cub when she's to put his paws on
the logs and kind of lay her heads back
and try and kind of look at you and it
reminds me of when she was little at
this time sort of last year
it's just one happy cat at the stage
unfortunately I didn't think it's gonna
be that long that she's that happy but
for now she's reveling in the fact that
she has a nice big meal and she's well
fed it's cooling down and so this is a
happy place for a young liquid to be
that's for sure
and she's got water close by - which is
even better I have a funny feeling we
came to see a lot of trauma this winter
around the lodge I think much like what
we were discussing earlier in that she's
going to be much like husana in many
respects she's going to be that kind of
cat that spends a lot of time in this
area what I hope it'll be that way
good we'll stay here we've probably
until you know the end of the evening
and in the meantime let's send you back
across the Steve who apparently is doing
a sunset showdown indeed we're gonna
have leopard and sunset shots at the
same time Tristan now why don't all the
viewers put a quick little pole through
there to tell us who's sunset was
prettier my own on David's or Tristan
addicts with syndrome keys
houses through black monkey orange bush
I'm very very artistic David figure to
stick but why are we being so testing
should we jump back over to the labor
that we've managed to find he stood up
walks away okay well let's art works
everybody that's how it works
she was lying down next to us and Dave's
artistic nurse I led to us am looking
away from her for a moment and all it
takes is a moment and a moment later
she's gonna get up and walk away so
that's the way it works everybody we are
live
we are interactive there's nothing
stopping these animals from moving
however they would like to the only
difficulty we have from time to time
is keeping up I'm just gonna punch
through over here so I get past this
other vehicle I think we're a little bit
smaller than they are they also go
through these little branches a little
bit easier than yesterday we've got
visual over there just get around the
side yeah it starts to open up a bit the
black monkey orange develops into these
very thick stands now you can see how it
suddenly disappeared here it is a very
well renowned pushing Crozier so
okay so let's see if we can spot it yet
he's just disappeared
she is Davi I was just going through
over there
Emily she takes after her mom like that
turned II can just vanish dwell okay
stop he's got it
she is
moving through the thickets luster
yeah we've lost it let's come around
there the Sun it's very sick there I'm
gonna go pushing food
okay well let's try find kochava
and while we there we go she's turned
and while we do that let's go to her
niece who's eating some food once again
well that's what happened Steve when you
try and start a competition without
stating that there's a competition to
start with and trivita son sit then you
lose a limpid for karma and that's what
happens because sins and I didn't state
that it was a competition you were just
admiring son and then Steve tried to
make it something and now he'd like I
say the car me is that he's lost his
lipid cuz he was cheating anyway
Columbia has since waken up it's perfect
timing we left her she was sleeping we
came back and took us I mean you what
five minutes and she's awake again
and having another little feed and there
is a very very upset squirrel that has
now disappeared but unfortunately the
the stump behind us in that if you can
show it but to the right so there's a
little dead tree that's a broken off
tree now there's a squirrel living
inside there and Columba being where it
is means the squirrel who's trying to
come out and move off can't go anywhere
because she's right chill all the time
and is very unhappy about this situation
and constantly a shelter which is not
good because the noise that that
squirrel makes could very easily attract
various other predators in this area
look at how nice that little light is on
her face I mean obviously there's
stomach content everywhere which is not
so nice but it's nice it's kind of light
on her face itself just go impress that
she managed to actually bring this down
there really is an incredible feat for a
small lipids are strong these impalas
are it just gives you an idea of how
strong the cats are themselves and
particularly lipids they're known to be
one of the stronger sort of predators
part four pound me as clean your nose is
full of blood Cantus red nose when is
red nose day there used to be a thing
called red nose day you say you say well
the Impala is bigger than her yes it is
by a long way actually yeah you don't
really get a sense of it now that she's
turned the Impala but earlier she had
the Impala side on and was feeling kind
of behind it and the Impala is massive
in comparison to her much bulkier than
what she is
so I'm afraid her ability to bring this
army is great but still a long time
until she's gonna be able to hold on to
kilts like this she's got a lot more
work to do
dude at the end of the yard no I mean
yeah I think it's a South African thing
I'm not sure it may be you guys gonna be
no Red Nose Day is it a worldwide thing
I know in South Africa it used to be a
big thing it's not so much anymore but
it used to be massive in in South Africa
everyone would put on a red nose and at
school and things used to think was very
funny
is it a British thing but worldwide em
is giving me a all the information as
I'm talking about it but when is it
though am I gonna have to Google for me
so that I know what dates it is
but Columbo kid competes in that today
because she's got a little red nose from
all the blood that she is it collecting
as she's eating Kirstie is googling off
now we've got the two redheads in
control of our show this is going to be
something the two of them are like a
little ninja clan that control what goes
on in in if see and make sure that all
the right decisions get made I'm gonna
be scared when the two redheads are
together because otherwise you name one
false move and then they ninja you and
pay you're in big trouble
so I laughter we have to be on our best
behavior sins oh yeah otherwise we're
gonna be in trouble with the - you know
what sins let's try and see I sense it
let's move and see if we can get a for
you from the front and which I would
like to but I think there's gonna be a
bit of foliage since you think we can
sneak in here let's try okay we're gonna
try and sneak through this little gap
you can see beautiful orange Sun just
careful your head sins sharp thorns
there
you all right like I said good good good
not piercing you house that's there is
that good more just double-checking
because the camera is lying in my line
is a little bit different sensors trying
to sort out our aerial as well because
we negotiated that area but I think this
will be a slightly better angle for us
oh there's a stick hold on since let me
just go slightly forward for you let's
just see if we can get rid of that stick
in front of her face no back afford
there's good
unfortunately the stick is not gonna go
anyway I'm afraid so we're gonna just
have to deal with the one stick that is
in front of her face and quite a few
organs that are there as well so if
you're a bit squeamish now it's the time
to probably look away because you can
see she's been chomping a bit on the
liver there and then there's the rest of
the internal organs that are kind of
behind that not sure I'd want my nose in
there you think it would smell that good
although it's funny enough when she open
the stomach you could smell and it smelt
just kind of like rumen does which is
not really that pungent it's funny it
doesn't actually smell too bad at all
it's kind of got a kind of grass he sort
of smell to it I mean in the race just
smells like blood which is not too bad
when it's fresh it's in two three days
time this carcass would absolutely he
with the scent of death but for now it's
all just fine because of how fresh it is
you're going to have a big tummy by the
end of this how can you hear her as she
chews through the skin
alarm oh yeah yes anatomy class 101
thanks to Columbo with this lecturer at
Columbia actually we should do um she
goes through all the sort of organs and
you can see all the little bits inside
there like I said but but on the McCobb
side to look at for long periods but
interesting to kind of see how it's all
arranged when it's inside I mean it's
moved a bit because she's been feeding
commit essentially you can kind of
roughly see how it's all arranged
apparently you can also hear a chewing
quite nice it's nice when she grabs the
skin because that makes a lot more noise
than the rest
but you can see how she feeds now it's
quite interesting how she uses her
canines and basically to rip and pull up
and break the sort of bits of meat and
then from there she gets it into the
side of the mouth and then she'll
basically uses carnassial's to cut
certain and sever that fish from the
bone or wherever it's attached or just a
chunk of flesh itself so it's an
interesting kind of way that she feeds
she uses the front of her mouth and then
turn sideways to be able to break it but
I believe we're winning the sunset
challenge since that's exciting
well dance Enzo it's all sensors work I
didn't do much in fact our sunsets
actually got invaded talking of the Sun
state you can see little Columba she's
still feeding so we'll show you one more
time what it looks like now the Sun has
gotten a bit lower and it's a beautiful
orange color and you can see there's a
little bit of haziness in the air and
this is more those kind of call them
dirty sunsets that we get in the winter
months and generally these are caused by
the fact that a lot of dust gets into
the air and it's starting to happen now
because we're having so little rain that
more and more dust is being blown up and
you kind of get these more I don't know
what the word is they're not as crisp
and clear as the Sun sets after a good
rain storm this one seems like it's a
little bit dirty and the bear is a bit
hazy from the dust that's in it's a
typical kind of wintry Sun sets when you
get a Sun like that and there's the bush
off to the west
looking very very good at the moment all
that means are you you've done a
sterling effort with your sunset today
right we'll keep sitting here I mean
there's not really much else to go and
do I think we are going to hope for ting
Ghana's arrival as well as the Juma clan
maybe we'll get them all here at some
point and in the meantime let's send you
back across to Lauren very very sleepy
cats and but different lions surprise we
have changed sexes and we are now with
two very handsome meals known as the
Kichwa boys and these boys were also the
ones involved in Oh lalala river pride
dispute and here they are and guess what
they're doing sleeping if we just look
at the one at the back now I really wish
it would put his head up on cue but it
probably warned
you can see the black color of that mean
at the bottom is actually really really
dark when we arrived here they did at
least put their head up to acknowledge
us and it is a huge mane of thick black
here and these males really are in their
prime prime very dominant and they have
been seen mating with both the although
low lows and the river pride which is
most likely why they stayed out of the
dispute you know if you're messing
around with all the ladies you probably
better not get involved in any sort of
dispute no interest in saying so Steve
Davi competing with the sunset you
haven't seen the Mara sunset yet we're
not quite at that stage but I assure you
I will try and champion them all with my
dramatic skies it may not be a beautiful
sunset because there's lots of clouds
but it will be dramatic and it will be
beautiful so the challenge is on now I
said this about every Lions we've seen
we've seen a lone lioness we've seen the
river pride and here we have the boys
that we were looking for earlier and I
keep saying it's getting cooler skin and
dark are they're gonna stand up and my
goodness they are they they just haven't
moved the sort of paler male towards the
tree he hasn't even opened these eyelids
I don't think he looks really
comfortable and he's just completely in
his dream world so I cannot believe the
number of lions that we have seen in a
number of cats that he are an Juma have
seen they are obviously all celebrating
fun day Sunday yeah we might put a
little bit catnip here and they are no
I'm only joking of course we didn't it
just is an extremely lucky cat they I
don't think I've ever seen this high
number of lions and one drive before so
I'm in a bit of a pickle do I stay with
the boys or do I go back to the river
pride oh it's a big choice for me
because the river pride are not in the
best position quite far away for us to
get a good view and these boys are
literally within arm's distance they are
so close just snoozing by the tree here
so I'm in a bit of a pickle but I would
really really like to see these boys
stand up I haven't as been
sometimes ins of Spain yeah I think my
Ohioans have spent some time with male
lions actually we did have Kapoor Lee
before I went away for a few days but
other than that is always been lionesses
so I think my heart is telling me to
stay here with the boys and as you know
I didn't mention the darkness of their
means is very strongly directly
correlated to testosterone levels so
this just proves that these are indeed
very prominent and dominant males in
their prime and a male lions prime is
said to be around five to seven years so
I the this must mean that these lines
are right and they're their prime and
Chris is saying that this is half tail
and fun I think that was the two names
that Chris mentioned and indeed I
believe it is so finally I have managed
to ieg some lions who still are
struggling with that first lioness but I
will get there took lots of photos and I
promise you I really really will get
back to you on who that lioness is but
these are the Quechua boys and yes Chris
I believe you are right I am wondering
actually I think this is the first time
I have had a very cool sometime during
with the kichwa boys I don't have the
best memory in the world but yes I think
it is so hello boys it is a pleasure to
meet you oh look at this this one's Joe
move and while he's sleeping oh that's
so cute okay I'm gonna keep my eyes open
forever dramatics guys that are gonna
champion Juma but for Anaya while I stay
with my sleepy boys we're gonna send you
back down to the beautiful kochava
well Lauren thank you for linking back
to us I know it's exciting to see the
kids your boys but well we've got a good
Chava the beautiful female here but I've
been a tree the sort of stereotypical
Leopard shot in the sabi sands of a
leopard perched atop a marula tree
looking at one of the most beautiful Sun
sets I mean you can actually see the
glow of the sunset on her face as well
leopards also take a bit of time in
their day to enjoy the sunrise and the
sunset as we do and I wish both Lauren
and Tristan well on beating our sunsets
at this afternoon they're not really a
competition it's all about us providing
the beauty for you and then you are to
decide I mean how can you even talk
about sunsets with the amount of
leopards and lions that have graced us
with the presence that's afternoon a
beautiful and beautiful girl
so this is a strategy they employ as
well for catching animals because the
leopards got a much better view up in a
tree there they can obviously have a
very nice nap considering that they
can't get snack upon by a pride of lions
or high you know so they can have a
proper little sleep but then also if any
movement happens to sort of betray and
animals camouflage somewhere in the
thickets she'll be able to see it race
down the tree to be able to catch it and
catch you one of the females develop
juleps and know it is something that is
designed for males is designed for
protecting the male's neck making him
bigger stronger thicker intimidating I
think those are the main reasons for the
dewlap but not all males develop a big
jewel app it is probably a genetic thing
as well maybe a testosterone thing we
noticed was Sylar before he disappeared
it was only slowly starting to develop
one and his father has got a magnificent
one but I've seen leopards in the past
that haven't really had a very
well-defined a dewlap and I'm sure a lot
of its got to do with genetics
even in fula when I last saw him looking
quite skinny had store their eminence of
the jewel upon him
very pretty
so as I said it is raining a cat's this
afternoon and consulting detective you
loved dangly legs well she's sitting
like such a lady isn't she sitting with
her on the side of her bottom there with
one leg down the side one perched up by
her head and sometimes you'll see
leopards are sitting similarly to this
except all four legs drapes on opposite
side of the branch and they get quite
uncomfortable with the full belly of
meat but she looks rather in her element
doesn't she and the tail hanging just
off to the right to add in some
wonderful sort of wonderful sort of
balance
you can hear the sounds of another
vehicle they've just come in to enjoy
there's wonderful sighting yep
in Chitra
okay well from aunty who's looking
rather hungry and rather snoozy let's go
back to Tristan who's within he's
playing with her in parlor meal
well that's not really a nice what
you're looking at there the nieces
behind busy feeding away that's a little
bit more kind of it's quite a close-up
of those organs but it is indeed Java is
is the aunty of Colombo because it's no
its older sister that's that's right
it's not Denise Chavez older sister I
don't even know why I thought it was her
niece for a second day um there was the
same mother potentially different
father's more how many kochava looks so
much like a mullah but she's proven to
be in bulla Colombo we've sent off her
stool sample now so we'll see what comes
of that they were taken last week so
it'll be interesting to see what her
paternity test comes back as I mean we
we say it in Ghana and duties behavior
around her but we'll get hopefully
conclusive proof that it is her Azrael
so santoku Mary's DNA off as well which
is good news it will at least be in the
library and will be interesting to see
which Cubs he's fathered over the next
few years comes that Panthera project at
least is still going on and and
hopefully will continue for a long time
to come it's not obviously I need to do
with paternity and maternity and all
these kind of things it's also to try
and do DNA testing and sampling of as
many lipids as possible to try and saw
it's kind of ending the trade of lipid
skins within South Africa so a lot of
the testing that's taken place is
sampled and it's not just here in the
sabi sands those those samples are taken
and then whenever they recover any sort
of skin and that is a real skin they
then do your DNA test on it and they can
actually figure out from where those
come and what's quite scary is that
there was some skins that were found in
Natal which is a part of South Africa
this oral eastern coast of South Africa
a
markers that matched one or two of the
lipids here in the sabi sands which is
pretty insane so but very very long time
ago not any time recently before anybody
panics
they old old skins and old kind of DNA
markers that have been had and very far
removed it's not direct descendants that
are kind of Cubs or anything like that
so before neon panics before anyone
states that kuru Lewis
taken or anything like that it's not
that and it wasn't even crewless lineage
neither before that happens because I
know how people like to jump to
conclusions when it comes to these
things and it is most definitely
categorically not the case that her
family is even involved in this it was
nothing to do with with the lipids from
the northern sabi sands at all
now since I'm gonna go forward a bit for
you you just said that you don't have
that pushing in the way
you look very Smits and young lady
but anyway it's an important kind of
process that they're going through and
hopefully will continue to go through I
have I left one branch in front of your
face I have haven't I no there we go
that's okay
yes clean that face make sure that you
are well groomed I have this funny
feeling that she's going to just pass
out and see fairly shortly and we're
gonna have to try and kind of search and
be very patient with her over the course
the next hour as full as that Bailey
gets the most kind of sleeping she's
gonna do right no it sounds like the
sunset challenge has gained momentum and
Lauren now wants to compete so let's
send you up to the Masai Mara and see
what East Africa has got for us I'd just
throw myself into the challenge I wasn't
really invited to be honest and you know
what I'm just gonna judge my own sunset
okay I may be bending the rules here it
is technically a sunset but of course
it's not gonna be the type of sunset
that I know Tristan or Steve showed you
however I myself am declaring myself the
winner of the dramatic skies isn't that
just stunning
pinks purples a little orange glow with
all these dramatic hopefully not too
heavy clouds I declare myself the winner
of the dramatic sky so thank you Tristan
for not inviting me into the challenge
that will be remembered however it is
just absolutely wonderful to look at and
a more seconds me so I have backup isn't
that fabulous now we have moved to give
you the sunset but we're gonna try and
go back to the boys it won't be the best
angle is probably a little bit x-rated
however I'm just gonna show you who is
who cuz we managed to get a good look at
them so they were on the other side now
and the darker one is half tail short
tail sorry because you can see or
probably you can't see when he just
moved his to you he's actually missing
the end section the tip of his tail it's
not a stumpy one like the chao-li boys
it's just missing the last sort of
segment of his tail and then on the left
a much paler one is
so that's who these boys are and even
when we turned on the engine and decided
to move they really haven't moved a
muscle so I apologize about this few
it's definitely not as pleasant as the
other view so what we're gonna do is
just move back around and we'll try and
get their faces again for you and while
we do that we're gonna send you to Gigi
who is somewhere over that way with Cubs
very good job ah Lawrence have gotten
the key tremolo we I it's just windy and
windy and windy you can see how the
trees are being blown by the wind but
these Cubs are not being moved by that
wind because they're saying this is our
trophy our mothers our auntie's did a
very good job we are not going anywhere
well ladies and gentlemen I am back to
the Associated tree pride and we've got
two cups they are one female on the
right two youngsters right on top of
that one and the female to the left
there that just brought yeah exactly
that is it in the back of that Buffalo
there it is called Limpy now finally
because of the wind you remember for
those of you who are with me before I
was saying I could smell the caucus but
I couldn't tell where it was but I knew
once the wind would come I could hear Oh
in in a particular direction and one I
didn't know what caucus it was or what
and more what French was but now I've
been able to identify it it's Buffalo
they have done it again and if I'm not
shown it is another male Buffalo why
they don't break down females I do not
know but in general nine out of ten
times this pride brings down buffaloes
that is olympia that's her name the ones
just moving there
Kaleem good question there and you're
asking who Eddie the tum tugger boys
come from I mean there have been some
two theories number one buffaloes are
not easy to kill and when lions go for
them claim they have been known to hunt
lions and they have been known to go
them using their chaperones you know
carrying a dagger that people use I have
seen not I can't remember what countries
but I think it could be the immense
where either the sole tons of the Kings
would carry daggers in the very special
sheath now those daggers are always big
and very sharp but also in South Africa
dagger could be it could also mean mud
but he ain't Kenya for us when you see
the dagger boys we always mean the
buffalos and more so Killeen the mayors
because if the buffalo ancestors and so
and most of the male as I said would get
not only the Lions but even as locusts
it usually hurts people and they have
been known even after killing people
they have been known to shred people
have been known to tear people's clothes
they have been known to shred people's
bodies and clean that's where the name
dagger boys came from well I do not know
how dagger boy this is but the saucy
trip right have always come out
unscathed or an hurt by the buffalos now
I got two females here I'm still yet to
account for the other three and before I
left this sighting I had three and I was
missing - now I got two missing three I
will need to see all the five and I
would say they are all in good shape
because this Buffalo to me looks like he
was a big boy you just look at him and
he was very well-built
as much as they go down they go down
fighting now I don't what I don't
understand is that little cab there you
know sitting very close to Limpy not
eating
Irish where we are now this area is
called the sausage republic or rather is
the territory for the sausage females
Irish Lions are very territorial and
Hoya Laura DS is such a long way from
here
so that particular territory your Laura
knees have different pride males now
Irish the pride much for this pride here
I've called the hold on your back look
at what leap is trying to be to turn
around that Buffalo so it's very
difficult for the kitchen males to get
here because if they do they are going
to get a very a big fight from the pride
males of these females that is called
the old Anya pike now what limpy's
trench it is to turn around that carcass
and maybe to be able to reach too much
fresh or much softer flash or guests and
maybe also help the Cubs to reach you
know some soft meat because what it is
now is so much thick skin and the Cubs
cannot do much all right
limp let's go 1 2 3 pull Limpy let's go
one more time Limpy now she may need the
hand of another female or she may need
the hand of the males now the first time
I got here I did not see any males and
not even now but I know they are not far
but what would be interesting is if the
males would arrive one of them I can
tell you all these females or the Cubs
are going to step back and allow the big
boy to eat limp you got some job to do
there you may need to call your sisters
or your cousins to give you a hand there
it's not easy what she is trying to do
ideally what Liv is trying to do is to
turn over that caucus and then the Cubs
get access of the much softer meat as
always as it is now it's just skin the
skin could be about half an inch or
one inch thick it's very difficult for
the Cubs to just dig in their teeth to
reach the soft meat so either limp he
will have a low commercial break have a
rest or just go and call your sisters or
cousins to come and give you hunt blame
should he do that now look at her as she
walks he's very easily pick she lives a
little bit but not always sometimes she
walks nicely but then you can see how
she throws her head up well I'm staying
with these clients a little longer I'm
not going anywhere and I also believe
Steve Oval has gone back to the new
comers we have indeed David we are with
Lions that have not only finished eating
a meal they've spent the day slumbering
now missing one member it's possible
they're trying to find her
you know go home a pride for them
leading the way
of course it's the females leading the
way males are still sitting over there
and they are
there's the oldest lioness not to arrive
next to looks to be the monkey in email
let me just check his face yes
laughs the sound of lions calling
it's just a soft mmm contact call try
and find out where their missing members
are
they're walking back in the direction
where the head that you're off baby
giraffe this morning
can you see her she's covered in was
probably stomach content everybody
and being very vertical this evening
excuse my silence everybody but this is
such wonderful noises
is a proper baby wobble they father's
gone Apple is a male here a couple more
youngsters in there two of them have
gone down to drink but I have no doubt
they were all gonna follow each other in
a moment
context almost lacquered and sulky noise
[Music]
such wonderful sounds here
now being very very vertical
they were behind on the side of that
tree yeah
love shared amongst family Hardwick
flopped on the floor see the size
difference between the female and the
male on the right
and be of similar age
working off their Danette and their
breakfast
contech calling as they go the problem
is where they're headed
could either be home it's a little Gary
could be South they could go into Juma
let's hope everybody hold cross fingers
they go into Juma so we can follow them
could go either way right now
crossing all of our fingers those of you
who forgotten or not aware we do have a
TV show starting and hot bus six know
about half an hour or so and well we
would like to show our south african
guests our lovely pride of lions she's
got a bit of a limp this one does happen
they do injure themselves in hunting you
jump onto the back of the giraffe and
maybe fall off it's possible to injure a
leg or sort of oh wow there we go that
line that's me that is the vine gain
email for short
look at the size difference there
between him and that lioness yeah I
think that's all of them are we gonna
try to get up ahead try and get a bit of
a view in front of these lines they're
headed sort of in that direction sort of
West ish and north so if they just
follow the road LP and rumor and last
would that be
okay so we're just gonna drive them
along the sides and see if maybe we keep
up with them
well thanks for staying with us during
that folks that was awesome to see all
the action or the the noises but there's
nothing more rewarding than watching
crazy lion cubs
well Steve I agree with you and ladies
and gentlemen you'll notice now that the
same Lions you're seeing a few minutes
ago may look different simply because we
have gone through infrared it has gotten
a little bit darker here and we thought
let's not shine anything artificial to
these Cubs and we are now in what we
call infrared camera same camera but you
just make sure that nothing at Fisher
will go to discuss not to affects their
behavior they'll continue eating the
continue drink what we're doing and
we'll continue also enjoying them I'm
sure you know we are always one hour
ahead of South Africa and more from the
North sometimes it gets darker here than
it does in Juma the wind is still
blowing and one thing that will not
change these cuts are not going to leave
at this a buffalo they're not going
anywhere and if anything that should
make them rise up and behave differently
would be anything like China but not
rain not wind and not Sun they are here
to stay the Cubs now what they did they
just thought they better go around and
try and sneak and dig for themselves
some kind of soft meat you can't see
that one what an angle he got who gets
that's a boy they're trying to reach the
mid from you know the other side of the
Buffalo but even asked out of Gaunt
round the other side just go right in
and feed so we got now three females I
can't see yeah the other two vouloir but
right in front of me a boom gave you
soon a bit to the right
this one mama there and just next to her
to him out thank you very much you see
that one there yes the tron I'll be able
to identify who she is can hear some of
the Cubs calling no she can hear because
of the wind
where you going to the one okay you
wanna go somewhere maybe able to the
bathroom any good mother will keep an
eye so she see she's looking as much as
you know she's walking away okay that's
another mother has woken up it's very
maternal for the mothers to make sure
that everything goes right ask the wind
continue blowing here maybe they're
going for a drink who knows the mother
is trying to follow them so we do indeed
so what want to do is to go back to this
to cabin
let us still on the kill and find out
whether they are getting lucky because I
think the mothers need to turn this
Buffalo the other around otherwise them
struggling struggling well as you find
out if the females will come and turn
around this Buffalo for the Cubs
let's go back to Lauren cuz I think huh
males are up and about
well 50% of the Quechua males are a week
and half tail here I have such an issue
saying half seal because he actually has
his fool tail is just the tip that's
missing so apparently he also gets
called snip and I much prefer that name
but we're gonna stick with half deer
which isn't quite accurate but we'll
stick with that is giving us a glorious
view of his mane let's take a closer
look it that mean it is fabulous and you
can even see all the word and I are
right now we're using our infrared
camera you can pick young it's a hard
life being a male lion isn't it so you
can even see the contrast and colors
between the sort of really orange a
phone color with that dark black mean
that explains okay well he obviously
wasn't overly amused at us talking about
his mane
that but you weren't able to see the
contrast and he did setup and that was
absolutely perfect it extends it extends
all the way down his back hands all the
way down his chest he is an hour
standing up thank you have till we look
a bit stiff there is that a limp or is
that a stiff leg I am not entirely sure
they are oh very good just for the end
of the show he decided to collapse
disguise himself amongst a long so we'll
take one last look at San here who does
have his tail intact but it has a rather
funny mouth and missing canines so they
both sustained injuries in their life
but they're definitely males and their
prime and they are absolutely glorious
so I do hope they stand up shortly and
entertain us however I'm very happy to
see them for now so please do join us
tomorrow on our Sun Rise Safari I'm sure
you're all happy its back see you then
[Music]